Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wo sind wir hier? Diesmal in der echten Garderobe.
Wir sind wirklich in der Garderobe. Draußen ist schon das Publikum, es tobt schon fast, kann man sagen, und wir gehen gleich raus, denn es ist wieder Live-Salon in der CASE in Frankfurt. Richtig.
Was machen wir hier?
Karneval. Ja, die Leute haben unser Cover ja schon gesehen. Ja.
Ich habe mir tatsächlich die Mainzer Fernsehsitzung Mainz mit Mainz angesehen. Und zwar ist das ja eine Sendung, die sagt, hier findet Politik statt. Und da dachte ich mir, ja eine politische Karnevalssendung, die muss ich mir doch unbedingt ansehen. Und es ist eine Sendung, die natürlich die Mitte der Bevölkerung erreichen will. Und im Saal sind auch Politiker, die zuhören. Das heißt, das sind wirklich Eclipse für die Ewigkeit. Zum Teil hat man den Eindruck, aber auch grauenhafte, um es gleich dazu zu sagen. Und ich habe noch Clips mitgebracht über Superjachten. Denn auch da gibt es eine neue Bescheidenheit. Davon werde ich dir erzählen.
Neue Bescheidenheit bei den Superjachten?
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Wir gucken, bevor Wolfgang Karneval guckt, Karneval. Wir hören. Ja, also wir hören. Es sind ja Podcasts. Männer machen Podcasts. Ja, wir hören uns an, wie Männer diese Podcasts beginnen, wie sie uns sagen, worüber sie reden, wie sie mit Gesprächspartnern umgehen und so weiter und so fort.
Wo sie retten die Demokratie dabei nämlich an.
Es geht immer um die Demokratie.
Ah ja.
Also wer sich fragt, warum redet Gordon Rapinski im Springer-Podcast Politico mit Kra von der AfD, aber nur für 200 Sekunden? Und was kann man in 200 Sekunden verhandeln? Der kriegt heute die Antwort.
Ja, ich bin sehr gespannt darauf. Du hast dich dadurch 100 Stunden durchgekämpft. Respekt in Mainz, weil Mainz dauerte nur vier Stunden. Also das war nur eine geringe Vorbereitung für mich.
Vier Stunden, die ich, ansonsten ist ja so, du bringst politischen Kram mit.
Ja.
Und ich lass mich dann überraschen und stell fest, das ist ja ganz schön interessant, was du geguckt hast. Jetzt, wo du die Karnevalssitzung geguckt hast, konnte ich dir zurückmelden, hab ich schon gesehen.
Ja, ich bin total erschrocken darüber, ja.
Ich erkläre gleich warum. Ich find's auch ungewöhnlich, dass ich die schon gesehen hab, aber es ist, wie es ist. So, außerdem sagen wir euch, was wir im nächsten Salon lesen.
Genau.
Es ist ein Buch von Liz Peli.
Kennt man sie? Nein, sie ist eine Tech-Journalistin, Expertin, die sich mit Spotify auseinandergesetzt hat und sehr tief eingestiegen ist. Das Buch heißt Mood Machine. Kann man sich schon denken, wo es dahin geht, da so welche Stimmung da über eine Maschine hergestellt wird? Der Untertitel lautet The Rise of Spotify and the Costs of the Perfect Playlist. Es geht also darum, wie Spotify unser Hören verändert hat, die Musik verändert hat. Es geht um AI-Musik natürlich auch und wie diese Plattform so überdominant geworden ist und eigentlich unsere ganze Popkultur und unseren Gemütshaushalt auch mitbestimmt. Deshalb Mutmaschine und ich erwarte ihr Großes von diesem Buch.
Sehr gut, ich auch. Ich bin sehr gespannt, denn solcher Untertitel Die Kosten der perfekten Playlist, denkt man zuerst so, ist das jetzt so untertitelwürdig, aber man ahnt schnell, ja doch, die Kosten, die Perfektion und die Playlist. Ich werde wahrscheinlich dann, wenn wir das im Salon besprechen, vorher schon aus Athen berichtet haben. Ich habe mir die alten Heiligen und eben politischen Städten mal angeschaut und das Zentrum von allen ist das Dionysos-Theater. Was jetzt für mich bedeutet, das nächste Jahr wahrscheinlich, bin ich heuristisch nur auf der Suche nach dem Abklatsch, vom Abklatsch, von Abklatsch und der Renaissance, des Abklatsch des Dionysos-Theater. Da sind wir mit diesem Buch, da ich ja eh gerne über die Gemütszustände und Gefühle, Fühlsatzharte rede, ich bin sehr gespannt.
Also wir werden dann weiter einen Dionysischen Stefan erleben. Ich mach den apolinischen Wolfgang dazu mal sehen. Das ist ja der alte Konflikt, mal schauen. Jedenfalls freuen wir uns, wenn ihr den Live-Sanon hören wollt und wenn ihr dazu dann ein Abo abschließt. Das ist ganz einfach machbar über Steady. Man geht auf unsere Homepage neu20er.de. Dort findet man einen goldenen Button. Klickt darauf und kommt dann gleich zu Steady. Und ab drei Euro im Monat ist man dann dabei. Und es gibt natürlich noch die Möglichkeit über Patreon und über Apple direkt ist auch der Live-Salon buchbauen. Natürlich auch alle anderen Salons, die schon stattgefunden haben, kann man dann hören.
Genau. Jeder hört, wie er mag, aber wir bevorzugen, wenn ihr Steady-Kunden werdet, das ist für alle am einfachsten, am billigsten und am vollständigsten.
Dann sehen wir uns gleich live auf der Bühne.
So ist es. Bis gleich.
Guten Abend.
Hallo.
Man sieht schon Wolfgang, grau, grau, dunkelblau, weiß, ich schwarz. Es ist noch Karneval in Frankfurt.
Ja.
Wir nennen es hier Faschig.
Heute wird's närrisch.
Nährisch. Ja, so ist es. Was sagen wir zu Beginn? Möchtest du das Publikum begrüßen?
Wir freuen uns, dass ihr auch wenn Karneval vorbei ist, euch jetzt nochmal in eine Karnevalssitzung gleich begebt, um den politischen Gehalt zu destillieren. Aber bevor wir dazu kommen, haben wir natürlich noch ein paar andere Themen. Stefan bringt uns ein Destillat aus 100 Stunden Podcast, die er gehört hat. Ich find's unfassbar, dass du das überlebt hast, aber bin gespannt, wie die Ergebnisse sind.
Also ich stehe hier, aber ich leide immer noch. Mir ist auch ein bisschen übel.
Prima.
Ich hab den ganzen Tag schon gerätselt, woran es liegt, aber wahrscheinlich sind es einfach diese Podcast gewesen.
Das sind noch gute Voraussetzungen für eine Super-Show. Also einen schönen Abend, schön, dass ihr da seid.
Sorry, das Intro kam ein bisschen spät. Es ist also nicht nur langsam, sondern heute auch zu spät.
Was heißt langsam? Die meisten Leute hören es doch in einfacher Geschwindigkeit. Haben wir ja schon eruiert.
Es gibt neue Literatur. In der Zeit, ich habe sehr viele Hinweise darauf bekommen. Wir haben schon mal einen Text besprochen, in dem gesagt wurde, schneller hören macht Sinn und den Text gibt es auch auf Deutsch. Mit deutscher Forschung wahrscheinlich, wie auch immer. Wir gehen das im Salon dann durch. Also man darf schneller hören und das kann ich schon sagen, man wird dadurch auch klüger.
Durchs schneller hören.
Ja.
Okay.
Klingt unglaublich, ist aber wahr.
Wir setzen uns ja immer mal wieder mit den Leuten auseinander, die unseres Erachtens ein bisschen zu viel Geld haben und wollen das auch heute wieder verfolgen unter ein paar anderen Aspekten. So hörte ich beispielsweise den Chef-Talk, das ist ein YouTube-Kanal, dort werden wichtige Leute interviewt zum Beispiel. Den Nachfolger von Herrn Kühne, den wir ja schon bestens kennen aus dem Buch von Julia Friedrichs und von vielen Diskussionen, die wir schon hatten, also der Mann, der jetzt eine Oper in Hamburg bauen will, der aber selbst mit sich übrigens ja ganz geizig ist und alles überwacht, dass ja nicht jemand Reisekosten zu viel macht. Sogar war manchmal seinen Mitarbeitern, ich hab's im Handelsblatt gelesen, verboten, jeden Tag zu telefonieren, sondern er sagte ihnen, sie sollen einfach nur jeden zweiten Tag telefonieren, um die Telefonrechnung zu schmälern.
Finde ich gut.
Ja, auch eine schöne Idee. Jedenfalls sein direkter Nachfolger ist Karl Gernand und der mal in diesem Chef Talk Podcast zu Gast und wir hören jetzt erstmal so einen kurzen Zusammenschnitt, der so als Teaser dort zu erleben ist.
Mein Lebenslauf sollte zeigen, wo hast du Weichen gestellt?
Karl Gernand ist seit über 16 Jahren die rechte Hand von Klaus Michael Kühne, einer der erfolgreichsten deutschen Unternehmen.
Wo hast du zwischen zwei oder drei Positionen eine Option gewählt? Und warum kannst du diese Option erklären? Mit dem Talent schaffen sie erst in 10 Minuten. Und wenn wir im Fußballspiel bleiben, die nächsten 80 Minuten ist Disziplin. Ich verteufel Deutschland nicht. Ich sage nur, Deutschland muss sich wieder nach messbare Leistungen orientieren und nicht nach Wohlbefinden.
Und, und, und wir können uns denken, was noch so alles kommt in diesem Podcast. Sehr viele Sätze werden dort gesagt, wie man erfolgreich wird, bei denen natürlich immer auch das Gegenteil wahr ist. Also wir sind wieder im Reich der Bauernregeln dort und keine Sorge, ich werde diese Bauernregel jetzt nicht alle präsentieren. Aber dann, nach einer Stunde und 17 Minuten horchte ich plötzlich auf, denn der Moderator stellt folgende Frage.
Was würden Sie sagen ist heute genug und gibt es genug?
Ich glaube genug definiert sich danach, dass man mit einer Familie in einer Großstadt leben kann.
Ach, das ist ja eine interessante Antwort. Und ich dachte, was passiert jetzt? Und tatsächlich, es geht jetzt um die Wohnungsfrage.
Und wenn man sagt, man braucht für eine Familie, wenn zwei Kinder da sind und zwei Erwachsene, irgendwo in der Größenordnung von 120 Quadratmeter Wohnung und man zahlt heute 20, 25 Euro für einen Quadratmeter und man sagt, nach 30 Prozent seines monatlichen Einkommens sollte für eine Wohnung ausgegeben werden und nicht mehr, dann kann man das sich so langsam hochrechnen. Ich glaube, dass das Wohnungsthema das Entscheidende ist, dass man die Freiheit hat, dort zu leben, wo man leben will.
Also, er kommt mir gerade wieder bekannt vor. Er kam nämlich in den Abendnachrichten vor, als von der neuen Oper in Hamburg berichtet wurde. Und er ist dieser typische, nicht Gesprächspartner, sondern so kurze Wortspendengeber. Und er fällt dort auf durch so einen Spruch mit, ja, also so ein kühlrechnender Herr wie der Herr Kühne, der Kaufmann. Also 40 Milliarden Privatvermögen, so ein kühlrechnender Kaufmann wie der Herr Kühne. Da muss man dann und so weiter. Und dann ist ja das Konzept Hamburg steuert 100 Millionen bei und den Rest macht die Kühne-Dings. Und er meinte dann, ja, dann haben wir so Haltelinien eingebaut, bei denen wir uns dann auch mal in die Augen schauen und sagen, ob das alles noch so läuft, wie wir uns das vorgestellt haben. Also das ist für Kühne, große Kunst und so weiter will eine Operhaus bauen, aber dann guckt man sich immer in die Augen, ob diese fünf Euro noch genehm sind.
Jetzt haben wir schon gehört, 120 Quadratmeter, vierköpfige Familie, 25 Euro der Quadratmeterpreis. Und dann sollte es ja eigentlich so sein, dass man nicht mehr als 30 Prozent seines Haushaltseinkommens für die Miete verwendet. Das ist also schon eine ganz stattliche Summe und das Weiß auch gern hat. Und jetzt aber macht er uns Mut. Also man denkt ja jetzt mal so ganz kurz kommt jetzt was Klassenkämpferisches oder so, aber nicht. Man selbst mal hören.
Und so kann man sich das so ein bisschen hocharbeiten. Ich glaube, dass das heute auch, dass man ein sehr, sehr schönes Leben haben kann, wenn man ein Family-Inkomm hat, was irgendwo im sechsstelligen Bereich ist. Dann kann man in jeder deutschen Großstadt sehr, sehr ordentlich leben. Und die Chance hat jeder.
Hände hoch, wer fährt darunter?
Einfach sechsstellig verdienen, es ist so einfach und jeder kann das schaffen.
Vor allem in Hamburg.
Und damit war das auch, der Moderator hat dann noch so gesagt, naja mit der Chancengleichheit ist ja alles so schwierig, aber dann ist man auch einfach zum nächsten Thema übergegangen. Also das ist die Perspektive, die man hat, einfach sechsstellig verdienen. Da braucht man keine Mietpreisbremse. Hätten wir das mal vorher gewusst. Also ich finde, es ist so unglaublich, wie dreist das so vorgetragen wird. Also ich meine, man könnte sich ja so ein bisschen schämen, dass man so wahnsinnig viel verdient und dann irgendwie sagen, ja das ist schon schade, dass es so eine große Ungleichheit gibt und die Politik muss das auch als Thema sehen. Und dann kann man sich ja so rausreden, sich selber einen schlanken Fuß machen. Wäre ja noch verständlich, einfach so darauf zu reagieren. Naja, dann hab ich mir einen Podcast angehört, den Tomorrow Podcast von Tom Junkersdorf und dort war Martin Hager zu Gast. Er ist der Chefredakteur von Boote Exklusiv. Jene Zeitschrift, die Julia Friedrichs anfangs zitiert in Crazy Rich. Und dann dachte ich mir, interessant, was gibt's denn da so zu erzählen?
Was man ja beobachten kann und das mach ich tatsächlich schon aus beruflichem Interesse. Du hast das vorhin schon erwähnt. Ich mach das jetzt seit 21 Jahren. Bin ich in der Redaktion Boote Exklusiv und seit acht Jahren dort Chefredakteur. Ich beobachte diese Forbes-Liste der Milliardäre und auch sozusagen, wie sich der Reichtum entwickelt. Dazu gibt es jedes Jahr mehrere Wealth Reports, also Berichte, die genau beobachten, wie sich der Reichtum auf der Welt verändert. Und gerade bei den Milliardären ist das eben erstaunlich, wie viel Reichtum pro Jahr hinzukommt. Da sind wir jetzt glaube ich bei 1180, wenn ich mich nicht genau täusche. Ich müsste noch mal nachschauen, aber das sind pro Jahr, im letzten Jahr sind glaube ich 70 Milliardäre hinzugekommen.
Das klingt nur vielleicht auf der Bühne so, aber man hört ein bisschen Elmar Falani. Ist das bei euch auch? Wisst ihr wovon ich rede? Aladdin, Elmar Falani. Die beiden auf einer Bühne müsste man mal.
Ja, das wäre interessant.
Da muss man genau zuhören.
Ja, also natürlich rezipieren die Leute, die in dieser Luxusbranche zu tun haben, im Prinzip dieselben Studien wie wir. Wir sitzen da und sagen Mensch, diese Ungleichheit, wie furchtbar, diese ganzen Milliardäre und die sagen, ah ja wunderbar, da haben wir ja bald wieder neue Abonnenten. Wann kann man sich eigentlich eine Yacht leisten? Werden jetzt auch viele sich hier fragen, die mehr als sechsstellig verdienen?
Wenn du darüber nachdenken musst, ob du dir eine Yacht leisten kannst, kannst du sie dir nicht leisten.
Das gilt allgemein, wenn du ein Leben führst, bei dem du noch nachdenken musst, dann bist du kein Milliardär.
Ja, denn es sind ja nicht nur die horrenden Kosten, dass man da 30 Millionen, 50 Millionen oder dann sogar ein paar 100 Millionen ausgibt, sondern diese laufenden Kosten, die muss man ja auch hinzurechnen.
Als Beispiel, 45 Meter Jagd kostet es im Jahr mit Crew und mit dem Chef, also dem Koch und mit den Hafengebühren und dem Diesel, der benötigt wird, um von A nach B zu fahren, ungefähr 1,8 Millionen Euro an laufenden Kosten. Wenn man das nach oben rechnet, auf 75 Meter, dann bist du bei 3,8 Millionen. Also die 30 Meter Unterschied kosten dich 2 Millionen Euro laufende Kosten mehr.
Pro Jahr muss man sich also gut überlegen. Nun werden manche hier radikalisiert, vielleicht sogar durch uns am Ende, sagen, das geht doch so nicht. Brauchen wir diese Superjachten? Naja, hier kommt ein unschlagbares Argument, das ja auch schon mal Markus Lanz vor einer Weile gebracht hat.
Wie beispielsweise Sailing Yacht A über 140 Meter lang, drei Masten A 100 Meter hoch, 4.500 Quadratmeter Segefläche haben 400 Zulieferbetriebe mitgearbeitet. Plus eine Werft für fünf Jahre plus Designer und und und. Natürlich kostet das Schiff, keine Ahnung, einen sehr, sehr hohen Betrag, irgendwas mehrere hundert Millionen Euro. Aber trotzdem sichern diese Menschen, die sich dieses Stück Luxus oder Freiheit leisten, viele Jobs.
Wow, total.
Ja, volle Zustimmung. Also ich meine, das ist ja ein interessantes Wirtschaftssystem, wo man jetzt quasi davon abhängig ist, dass die Milliardäre sich genug Unsinn einfallen lassen, damit sie uns beschäftigt halten, damit wir wenigstens ein kleines Gehalt bekommen. Dass ja, mögen noch weitere große Schiffe gebaut werden. Du hast ja aufgrund einer Unterhaltung mit deinem Sohn diesen Begriff Willionär ins Spiel gebracht.
Ja, den. Ja, die Achtjährigen.
Es gibt nicht nur den Millionär, sondern eigentlich den Willionär oder die Millionäre sind Willionäre. Und im Prinzip sieht Hager das ganz ähnlich. Er wird gefragt, warum wollen Leute denn überhaupt so eine Superjacht haben?
Ich hab ein Sohn, der ist sechs, drei Kinder und der kleinste ist sechs, der liebt Lego. Der hat schon eine ganze Batterie an den Jago-Figuren, aber sein liebstes Buch ist der Lego-Katalog aus dem Spielzeugladen. Und obwohl er schon so viel hat, ist das Wichtigste, was kann er als Nächstes haben. Und er ist so leidenschaftlich dabei und dieser Wunsch, noch was davon zu besitzen, ist so groß, dass er immer wieder davon redet, wann kommt der Osterhase? Kann mir der Osterhase das bringen? Und dann geht es schon wieder und das ist aber ja nur eins, wann ist denn dann Weihnachten? Also es geht sozusagen wirklich, es ist dieser Wunsch, was zu besitzen und bei Menschen, die schon alles haben, ist das dann vielleicht genauso.
Hm, so mach ich das demnächst auch, wenn die Leute mich fragen, Stefan, du bist doch nah dran an diesem WMS. Wie tickt denn der so? Und dann denke ich mir so eine Geschichte aus mit sechsjährigen Osterhase. Und Lego. Ja, mal gucken, wie weit ich komme.
Im Prinzip sind wir ja alle so. Bei mir muss es noch eine Krawatte sein. Deshalb aber gilt es auch bescheiden zu bleiben. Und zwar gibt es dann den Begriff Stealth Wealth. Das ist also das heimliche Reichsein. Es gibt ja auch Quite Luxury und das hier ist noch mal auf so einer Stufe, dass man auch so generell nicht so gesehen werden will. Dieses Konzept stellt er jetzt vor.
Und da hab ich mich mit dem Thema Stealth Wealth beschäftigt. Sagt ihr vielleicht auch was? Also sozusagen der unauffällige Reichtum oder der Reichtum, der nicht so offen zur Schau gestellt wird. Das sind, da hat sich ein, gerade in der Modebranche, ein Geschäftsführer eines großen Unternehmens aus der Modebranche, hat sich ein Schiff bestellt in der Türkei. Bei Aliyah Yachts, 45 Meter, ganz ganz toll. Vom Design wunder, wunderschön. Und der hätte sich mit Sicherheit auch ein größeres Schiff kaufen können. Hat sich aber gekauft, 45 Meter.
Geht er auch noch weiter und es wird noch ein bisschen beschrieben?
Das Meer ist ganz nah, dadurch, dass die Scheiben so groß sind. Und wenn man es klimatisiert haben will, geht man rein. Und wenn man irgendwie in der Sonne liegen will, geht man auf Sun Deck. Und Jacuzzi ist natürlich auch drauf. Aber es ist jetzt nicht übertriebener Luxus, sondern das ist einfach wie ein Floating Villa irgendwo.
Ja. Oh Gott.
Und ich spiele das natürlich nicht nur zum Amüsement vor, wenn gleich ich auch sagen muss, ich hab im Zug gelacht, als ich es gehört habe, laut gelacht. Denn wir haben tatsächlich so einen interessanten Diskurs. Also man hat mal gesagt, diese Multimillionäre sind ein Problem. Dann hat man irgendwann gesagt, die Milliardär sind ein Problem. Jetzt inzwischen sagt man nur, naja, aber die Milliardäre, wenn die hier so Quiet Luxury und Stealth Wealth und so machen, also eigentlich sind es am Ende nur noch Jeff Bezos und Elon Musk. Also die beiden sind ein bisschen zu super, super reich. Aber die anderen dann vielleicht dann doch nicht so ganz. Sie haben ja auch Verantwortung, die sie übernehmen. Und das ist tatsächlich ein Diskurs, den wir vielfach finden. Und das war ja auch ein Problem, glaube ich an dem Buch von Julia Friedrichs mit Crazy Rich, dass es irgendwann so versöhnlich war wieder, dass man sagte, also bis auf Elon Musk und Jeff Bezos müsste man dann wirklich nur noch so ganz klein wenig umverteilen. Und dieser Diskurs zeigt eigentlich, wohin sich das schon alles verschoben hat. Also wir reden über Wohnungsgerechtigkeit ab dem sechsstelligen Einkommen. Quite Luxury ist 40 Meter Yacht statt 120 Meter. Man fragt sich, wohin kann es noch gehen? Jetzt muss man aber auch der Fairness halber sagen, diese Leute wissen natürlich schon, Klima ist ein Ding.
Die wollen heutzutage auch nicht mehr so negativ auffallen. Die versuchen schon, auch wenn die Schiffe natürlich groß sind, ihre Schiffe so zu bauen, dass sie einen möglichst kleinen ökologischen Fußabdruck hinterlassen. Das kann man jetzt glauben oder nicht glauben. Ich weiß, was diese Menschen investieren, um möglichst saubere Systeme an Bord zu holen, um die Ingenieure immer weiter zu fordern, Hybridsysteme zu entwickeln, die noch weniger sozusagen Kraftstoff benötigen.
Ja, also man weiß ja so, mit 5 Liter fährt so ein Ding ja auch ganz prima, wenn man es nur ein bisschen modifiziert. Nun ist es ja so, was macht man eigentlich auf so einer Jacht? Man langweilt sich natürlich, also braucht man etwas externes, ja? Ja, also man muss ja irgendwas tun, sonst geht man über Bord vielleicht aus Verzweiflung. Also holt man sich einen Gast, der Events für einen veranstaltet oder andere Leute bringt.
Bonnie Tyler.
Bonnie, diesmal nicht, ja. Aber sie hatte übrigens auch, zumindest ein Boot, ich weiß nicht, ob man schon Jachter zu sagen kann, hat sie auch, das ist wahrscheinlich der Grund, warum sie noch so viel singen muss, um diesen Unterhaltskosten immer zahlen zu können. Jedenfalls gibt es Jimmy Carroll, der hat sich darauf spezialisiert, irgendwas zu veranstalten für reiche Leute. Der hat auch den Draht zu irgendwelchen Profisurfern, die werden dann auch engagiert für einen Tag, wenn die Tochter des Scheichs mal gerne surfen will oder so. Und der wird uns hier kurz vorgestellt.
Jimmy Carroll, der hat einen vor sechs Jahren ein Unternehmen gegründet, das nennt sich Pelorus. Und er organisiert für all dry network individuals, diese superreichen, weltweit organisiert er außergewöhnliche Reisen.
Denn es ist ja so, am Ende ist das Reisen ja doch relativ günstig. Ja, du warst jetzt gerade in Athen, das ist bezahlbar. Ich kenne Leute, die jetzt gerade über den großen Teich geflogen sind, das kostet ein bisschen was, aber es geht so alles. Wo ist eigentlich noch diese Exklusivität? Wie schafft man es sich überhaupt noch von den anderen abzusetzen? Vor allem, wenn man Milliarden hat. Nicht, dass man am Ende wie ein Millionär aussieht. Das wäre ja auch tragisch. Ja, es geht natürlich auch so, dass man es mega exklusiv gestaltet und dabei immer auch Klimawandel in den Blick nimmt. Wenn auch aus einer anderen Perspektive.
Klar, dann werden dann Überraschungs-Dinner organisiert auf der Eisscholle vor Grönland. No way. Ein Dinner auf einer Eisscholle. Also der Eisbrecher fährt dann sozusagen so in das Pack-Eisfeld und dann wird von der Crew ein Tisch aufgebaut auf der Eisscholle und dann essen die. Und davon hat er gestern auch Fotos gezeigt. Da musst du schon sagen, okay, man weiß ja, nachher gibt's noch Lunch, aber du hast deinen Lunch eben auf einer Eisscholle im Pack-Eis. Das ist schon eine Geschichte, die lässt sich ganz gut auch zu Hause erzählen.
Denn Klimakatastrophe kann auch Spaß machen.
Ja, aber wenn die Eisscholle so klein ist, dass du es alleine machst, Dinner for One und zu Hause nur noch davon erzählen kannst, ist es, finde ich schon, nicht mehr ganz so viel wert.
Es ist, glaube ich, so mittels traurigste auch, was ich in diesem Jahr als Podcast gehört habe. Aber vielleicht kannst du das jetzt in anderer Weile toppen. Wir kommen zu den Männer-Podcasts, wie du sie immer nennst. Also es sind Männer, die über Politik sprechen bzw. mit Politikern sprechen.
Genau.
Und mit sich.
Männer, die mit anderen Männern über Politik reden. Und das ist auch wahnsinnig traurig. Also es werden weiterhin Clowns angezeigt, ist im Grunde auch so ein bisschen so. Aber okay, es ist auch Karneval, was wir jetzt gucken. Wir machen das so, es ist wirklich wahnsinnig viel, weil es ist ja so, man wacht ja morgens auf und dann gibt es einen neuen Table Media mit Michael Bröker und einen neuen Berlin Playbook von Politico mit Gordon Rapinski, Robin Alexander einmal die Woche, Rondsheimer und so weiter und so fort.
Also meine Tage sehen anders morgens aus. Ich will das nur ganz ausdrücklich betonen.
Ich meine auch jetzt auch.
Ich sage nicht hurra, ein Podcast von Gordon Rapinski ist da.
Also typischerweise machen wir ja auch ein leicht therapeutisches Gespräch über den Zustand der Welt. Für heute gilt, wir müssen auch lernen abzuschließen. Also ich. Alles, was wir jetzt hören, muss dann auch deabonniert werden. Also falls ihr das noch hört, das ist jetzt die Einladung zum Deabonnement. Jetzt fragen wir uns, falls ihr es nicht kennt, Ronsheimer. Wir haben ja schon ein paar Mal Ronsheimer Clips gehört. Ja. Wir wissen, wie er klingt. Er ist nicht schwer zu finden, denn der Podcast heißt wie er Ronsheimer. Also Paul Ronsheimer hat einen Podcast, der heißt Ronsheimer. Und wer den anmacht, könnte die Erwartung haben, dass dort einfach Ronsheimer zu hören ist, der halt eine Meinung hat über irgendwas. So einfach ist es aber nicht, denn die Weltlage und so weiter, die Stimmung muss hergestellt werden. Es ist alles so ein bisschen anders. Wir hören ja mal in einen klassischen Ronsheimer Podcast rein.
Mein Name ist Philipp Piertow. Ich bin Journalist und Kollege von Paul Ronsheimer. Und Paul kennt den ukrainischen Präsidenten Zelensky wie wenige andere Journalisten. Paul war auch während des US-Wahlkampfes bei den Republikanern. Er ist auch im Team von Donald Trump vernetzt. Und er war auch natürlich sehr, sehr oft in der Ukraine, in allen Teilen des Landes auch an der Front. Deswegen, um zu verstehen, was dieses Treffen auslöst, in den USA, in der Ukraine, in Europa, gibt es glaube ich keinen besseren Gesprächspartner. Deswegen guten Abend. Hallo Paul. Hallo Philipp. Deswegen redest du mal ausnahmsweise mit mir heute.
Es könnte aber auch ein Nachruf sein.
Ja.
Ihr dürft weinen, ja. Ihr dürft, ihr seid eingeladen, die Emotionen laufen zu lassen. Also überraschenderweise ist im Ronzheimer Podcast von Paul Ronzheimer, Paul Ronzheimer zu Gast, würde ich jetzt sagen.
Und man bekommt nochmal kurz erklärt, wer ist er eigentlich? Ja.
Eine Minute lang drehen.
Das wäre eigentlich auch toll, wenn wir bei jeder Folge uns nochmal gegenseitig vorstellen und nochmal auf unsere Bücher und so verweisen.
Genau. Wir müssen nochmal richtig erklären, wer wir sind, was wir tun. Welche Filme hast du zuletzt gesehen, wie hast du dich gefühlt und so weiter. So macht man dann fünf Stunden Podcast. Ein anderer, Gordon Rapinski macht für Springer den Play Berlin Playbook Podcast für Politico. Das klingt dort so.
Ich bin Gordon Rapinski, ihr hört den Politico Berlin Playbook Podcast für diesen Montag, den 10. Februar. 13 Tage noch bis zur Wahl. Und ihr seid hier ganz gut aufgehoben, denn wir beginnen jetzt. Jetzt.
Die heutige Folge wird präsentiert vom Verband der privaten Krankenversicherung.
Also Rapinski sagt ja immer, wann der Podcast beginnt. Ja. Jetzt. Jedes Mal sagt er immer jetzt. Und dann kommt erst mal dieser kleine Wärmung. Also falls ihr noch keine private Krankenversicherung habt, jetzt ist die Zeit dafür. Hajo Schuhmacher hat ein ganz interessantes Podcastkonzept. Ich konnte es erst auch selber gar nicht glauben, als ich es gehört hab. Da hab ich zurückgespult, hab es mir nochmal angehört, dachte mir, müsste ich doch eigentlich gut finden. Ich kenne doch meine Vorlieben. Wir springen da mal einfach so rein. Also Hajo Schuhmacher, auch so ein Urgestein und so weiter, hat natürlich die entsprechende Stimme dafür, um so Podcasts zu machen. Und was ihm fehlt ist, das findet ihr jetzt selber raus. Wir hören das mal.
Mein Name ist Hajo Schuhmacher, Journalist und Rumminer. Ja, ich experimentiere etwas rum mit diesem Format. Nicht wundern, die Stimmen, die ihr da hört, die nicht meine sind, sind von einer KI generiert. Interessiert mich, wie euch das gefällt. Und jetzt geht's los. Viel Spaß.
Und welche Sau treibst du heute durchs Dorf?
Ja, vielleicht zum letzten Mal die FDP. Wolfgang Kubicki, Chef-Entertainer dieser Partei, hat ja schon demonstrativ sein Büro aufgeräumt.
Ich sehe euch...
Und die KI sich die Antworten auch selbst aus oder?
Ich sehe euch erstarrt. Also habt ihr es nicht verstanden? Soll ich das Konzept nochmal erklären oder habt ihr es verstanden und findet es einfach blöd? Er redet mit einer KI.
Und das macht er immer?
Manchmal. Er experimentiert.
Ach so, er experimentiert.
Wenn er nicht gerade mit seiner Frau oder seinem Sohn redet.
Ja.
Also das sagt auch einiges über die Familie, wenn der Vater plötzlich in den Podcast-Keller geht und mit der KI redet.
Also mein Onkel hat eine Alexa und sagt, das sei die einzige Person, die noch auf ihn hört.
Ja. Heißt der auch Hajo oder was?
Nee, der heißt Manfred. Also ist aber ähnliche Generation.
So, jetzt ist ja so. Hajo Schumacher Mensch redet mit einer KI-Maschine. Wir hören jetzt ein bisschen weiter in diesen Podcast rein und beantworten danach die Frage, wer von beiden ist irgendwie klüger? Für wen haben wir mehr Sympathien? Ja, also Ohren auf.
An 2021 und die gecrafchten Jamaika-Verhandlungen. Es geht eben nicht nur um Knete, sondern auch um soziales Kapital. Und das heißt vor allem Vertrauen. Und das ist offenbar futsch.
Und an allem ist Christian Lindner schuld?
Na ja, wer den Laden seit 12 Jahren führt, bei dem wird es auch abgeladen. Lindners Problem ist der Verwechsel Taktik mit Strategie.
Hm, ja.
Die KI fragt, ob man allen Christian Lindner schuld ist.
Und die Antwort wäre ja ja.
Die Antwort ist ja total egal. Allein die Frage ist doch sensationell, die kann man doch so stehen lassen.
Ja.
Ist Christian Lindner schuld? Ja, liebe KI. Hajo Schumacher ist dann Wochen später zurück in seinem eigentlichen Podcast Business oder Setting mit seinem Sohn und kommt dann noch mal drauf zu sprechen, wie er das jetzt fand. Es muss ja therapeutisch aufgearbeitet werden. Man redet ja nicht alle Tage mit einer KI vor Publikum. Sagen wir uns mal so, er zeigt vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel, ich weiß nicht.
Dann sind wir wieder am Ausgangspunkt, dass dieser Dialog mit Chat-GPT mir wirklich, also ich hab viel gelernt in relativ kurzer Zeit. Ich hab mich einfach mit einem klugen, Menschen wollte ich gerade sagen, mit einem klugen System unterhalten. Bei allem, was man da vorwerfen kann mit Daten klauen und so weiter, fand ich ganz schön spannend.
Tolles Fazit. Redet er mit seinem Sohn, der typischerweise sein Gesprächspartner ist. Ich weiß nicht, wie du dich fühlen würdest, wenn ich einen Salon mit einer KI mache und dir dann drei Wochen später im Podcast sage, also die KI, das war schon ein ganz besonderer Podcast. Ich bin plötzlich so klug.
Ich fang so langsam an zu schwitzen und denke über meine Existenz so nach, im Ganzen und speziellen. Und hast du gehört, ich hab gerade ein Kind gehört. Wir haben also ein ganz junges Publikum heute. Ich will das wirklich betonen, dass die Range immer breiter wird. Ist das nicht großartig?
Vor allem ist das Kind dafür entschuldigt, nicht zu wissen, wo es ist. Denn wir hatten eine Nachricht, ich wollte es ja eigentlich noch mal vorlesen, aber so wie man in DMs reinslidet, löscht man auch, peinlich berührt seine Sachen wieder. Denn jemand, der heute hier ist, meinte, Stefan, ich bringe zwei Leute mit, die haben keine Ahnung, was ihr für ein Podcast macht, bitte lasst mich nicht hängen oder so. Da hab ich gesagt, sorry, das ist nicht unsere Aufgabe. Und daraufhin habe ich diese Konversation nicht wiedergefunden. Also wer ist das? Da. Okay. Wen hast du mitgebracht? Ah ja, okay.
Okay, also wir sind sehr gespannt, ob wir am Ende enttäuscht haben, bitte sagt es uns nicht.
Vor allem die Person neben dir sieht aus wie dein Vater oder jedenfalls Elterngeneration. Das heißt das Kind wird auch nachher noch nicht wissen, wo es heute war, aber ihr könnt das ja dann klären. So, Podcast-Business. Wann finden diese Männer Podcasts statt? Wochentage. Wir wissen ja Politiker arbeiten rund um die Uhr. So ist das auch hier. Gordon Rapinski erzählt hier mal eine ganz rührende Geschichte. Es ist sozusagen so wie in der Fazit, wenn man das literarische Leben mehr gelesen wurde als die Literaturbesprechung, ist das auch hier. Also dieser Metadiskurs, das Podcast-Leben, das Journalisten-Dasein steht so ein bisschen mehr im Mittelpunkt.
Und dann bin ich noch beim Feedback, um das ich euch ja gebeten habe. Und da gibt's eine schöne kleine Geschichte, die ich jetzt mit euch teilen möchte. Und zwar haben wir bei uns im Haus eine wunderbare Kantine, in der ich, wenn ich die Zeit dazu finde, zumindest auch immer mal esse. Und es gibt einen Stand, an den ich besonders häufig gehe. Und da ist Jan-Peter, der Koch. Und er bedient auch und er tut das mit großer Leidenschaft. Und meistens unterhält man sich ein bisschen. Und vor ein paar Wochen haben wir uns unterhalten. Und ich habe ihn gefragt, ob er eigentlich meinen Podcast hört. Und er sagte so ein Podcast ist eigentlich gar nicht so sein Ding. Und dann habe ich ihm gesagt, doch, ich möchte aber mal, dass er ihn sich mal anhört, wenn er sich für Politik interessiert. Und er hat mir ein ganz nettes Feedback geschrieben und hat gesagt, dass er mir ganz dankbar ist, dass ich ihm diesen Tipp mit dem Podcast gegeben habe und dass der Berlin Playbook Podcast sein morgendlicher Begleiter zur Arbeit geworden ist. Er hat gesagt, dass der Podcast an seiner Wahlentscheidung insgesamt nichts geändert hat, aber dass er viele Informationen bekommen hat und dass er sich animiert gefühlt hat, dadurch sich noch intensiver mit den Parteien auseinanderzusetzen. Und auch ansonsten sagt er, das Format findet er super, von der Länge bis zum Inhalt. Er hatte ein paar Kleinigkeiten. Er möchte nicht unbedingt ein Wochenend Podcast, sondern mag eigentlich diesen Montag bis Freitag, weil er Sonntag immer intensiv die Zeitung liest.
So, da ist also noch jemand, der Zeitung liest. Diese Kantine, das ist ja ein Springer-Produkt, wird wahrscheinlich in Berlin bei Springer sein.
Ja.
Und jetzt geht er in die Kantine und stellt fest, krass, hier ist noch jemand, der Zeitung liest. Und wir sind ja ein Zeitungshaus. Sollte ich den vielleicht hegen und pflegen? Oder sollte ich ihm sagen, nee, sorry, ab jetzt auch Sonntags Podcast. Können wir mal kurz überlegen, in welche Richtung geht das so. Wir switchen den Podcast Michael Bröker, Table Media. Podcasted nun auch samstags.
Das sollte Friedrich Merz einfach nicht machen, diesen Fehler.
Warten wir es ab. Das war jedenfalls unsere erste Schnellanalyse in unserem historisch ersten Sonntags Table Today Podcast. Ich freue mich, wenn Sie bis zum Ende dabei gewesen sind. Und morgen. Geht schon wieder weiter.
Genau. Und morgen ist ja aber neue Woche, da geht es schon wieder weiter. So, wir haben jetzt also Michael Bröker, der auch schon am Wochenende podcastet. Und Gordon Rybczynski, der immer sehr reflektiert, was er die ganze Zeit macht und sich die Frage stellt, sollte ich auch am Wochenende podcasten? Rybczynski ist sowieso immer ganz hart, also da gäbe es jetzt unendlich viel Clips zu spielen, wie er immer so sagt, und morgen am Freitag, ich weiß, es ist eigentlich ein Wochentag, wird es keinen Podcast geben, weil ich bin in der Regierungsmaschine oder was auch immer. Und dann sagt er so, da können sie dann ausschlafen. Also da haben sie dann keine Pflicht, mein Podcast, das ist so, die hier rangeht. So, also Michael Bröker, Rybczynski, podcasten die ganze Zeit, beziehungsweise die ganze Zeit, waren mal Montag, Dienstag, Mittwoch, Donnerstag, Freitag und jetzt auch historisch erstmalig, aber dauerhaft dann Sonntags. Was ist eigentlich mit dem Samstag?
Mein lieber Kollege, der Mann, der sich in der Innenpolitik am besten auskennt, am besten vernetzt ist, Michael Bröker von Table Media, hat trotz Samstag, früher Nachmittag, sich Zeit genommen, um das mit mir zu besprechen. Und obwohl ich immer noch in Kiew bin.
Ja, das ist ein voller Einsatz.
Genau, also Ronzheimer hängt in Kiew rum, möchte aber zur Innenpolitik, weil irgendein neues Paper, also ruft er den Bröker an, ob der nicht auch Samstag könne und da er ja eh schon Sonntag podcastet, kann man ja auch nach Samstag podcasten. Jetzt aber die Frage, wir wissen ja, dass man Podcasts auch vorbereiten muss. Wann macht man das dann, wenn man den ganzen Tag schon podcastet? Wir hören ja mal in ein Gespräch rein aus diesen Dingen, wo man sich Samstag morgens schnell zusammenschaltet, um nochmal das neue Paper und so weiter irgendwie, die wir im März ja Kanzler werden, um das durchzureflektieren. Und jetzt kommt eine Floskel, die wir alle schon kennen. Ich kenn da so einen Freund. Ich hab da so jemanden, ja einen Freund von einem Freund und so weiter. Und wir hören mal worum es da geht und überlegen uns, sagen sie nicht zu viel und lachen sie nicht auch ein bisschen an den falschen Stellen.
Ich hab durch einen Freund, der das Papier, was es da gab, also die Sondierung von SPD und Union, das hat er durch Chat-GPT gejagt und zwar mit der Fragestellung, wie sehr haben sich SPD gegen CDU-CSU hier in ihren Forderungen aus dem Wahlkampf durchsetzen können? Bitte als Tabelle im Ergebnis darstellen inklusive Punkte für voll, teilweise und einer Gesamtsumme je Partei. Und da kommt raus, ich lese jetzt mal das Fazit vor, insgesamt konnte sich die CDU-CSU mit 41 Gesamtpunkten stärker durchsetzen als die SPD, die 35 Gesamtpunkte erreichte. Ist das auch dein Eindruck?
Interessant. Also das ist durchaus mein Eindruck, wobei...
Mein Chat-GPT sagt ein bisschen was anderes.
Was ist denn das?
Ich glaube, das ist Doping. Hast du den größten Skandal mitbekommen, dass die norwegische Ski-Weitbrung-Mannschaft nachts, nachdem niemand mehr so genau hinschaut, die Nähte verändert, damit sie im Wind besser... Alle Welt fragt sich, aber gehört das nicht dazu? Ist halt eine Materialschlacht. Nein, es ist Material-Doping. Man darf sowas nicht.
Ach so.
Die beiden haben jetzt, finde ich, ziemlich deutlich zu erkennen gegeben, dass sie selber einander der Freund sind, der GPT benutzt, um aus elf Seiten Sondierungspapier mal kurz zehn Minuten Podcast-Material zu machen.
Und die Frage ist ja, bei dieser permanenten Podcast-Produktion, es suggeriert ja, dass die ganze Zeit etwas ist, worüber jetzt und nicht erst morgen gesprochen werden muss. Und das bedeutet ja, dass man suggeriert, es würde die ganze Zeit etwas geschehen, von dem man sagt, morgen ist schon wieder alles anders oder von dem man sagt, wenn wir jetzt nicht darüber sprechen, dann geht uns irgendwas verloren. Und der Witz natürlich dabei ist, das würde man gar nicht darüber sprechen, würde man sich in einer Woche wieder treffen, könnte man vielleicht einiges klarer sehen und hätte sich vieles erspart. Also es ist interessant, dass man eigentlich dann so eine Produktion hat. Also die Politik produziert quasi Material für die Podcasts und die Podcasts können dann in immer größerer Taktung arbeiten. Also es ist eigentlich so eine interessante Arbeitsteilung eigentlich auch. Und man muss deshalb auch diese Betriebsankeit, die ohnehin schon in Berlin herrscht, immer noch mehr beschleunigen, denn sonst hat ja Michael Bröker auch morgen nichts mehr zu erzählen.
Ja, also in der Zeit, als es noch Zeitung gab, war das ja so, das hab ich auch selber mal erlebt, da sitzt man in so einer Presseveranstaltung, in Reihe 5, es wird gequatscht, es wird geschäkert, es ist ja ein bewirteter Termin, es geht ja um Politik und so. Und dann hat man kurz nicht mitbekommen, was auf der Bühne gesagt wurde. Also geht danach die Floskel rum, wir warten auf die dpa. Weil jemand sitzt in Reihe 1 und weiß von mir hängt hier alles ab, hinter mir das sind nur Assis, die hören nicht zu, die schreiben nicht mit, die warten einfach, was ich als Akuturmeldung produziere und schreiben das dann ab. Und Ronsheimer möchte sich jetzt in dieser neuen Welt, in diese Position bringen. Ich muss das Sondierungspapier nicht lesen, weil Ronsheimer hat ja einen Freund, der GPT kann und der hat dann für mich das zusammengefasst. Und zwar so schnell wie geht. Also noch bevor ich in die Redaktion komme, kann ich ja sagen, ich hab heute morgen im Deutschlandfunk gehört, das ist ganz schön interessant, sollten wir was machen. Und man hat Ronsheimer gehört. Also er bringt sie einfach in so eine Pole-Position. Jetzt können wir mal überlegen, was für andere Positionen gibt es denn noch? Und wir wissen ja, es läuft viel über Zugang. Also Bröker wurde ja eben schon vorgestellt von Ronsheimer als niemand, kennt sich so gut aus, über Kontakte und so weiter. Wie Bröker. Hier möchte gerne Gordon Rybinski mitspielen mit einem ganz besonderen Format, denn man läuft rum, also man macht Spaziergänge. Man trifft sich draußen, wo du nicht so gerne bist. Nein. Und ich kann dir auch noch raten, ich höre jetzt nicht so ganz genau hin, denn jetzt wird es gefühlig. Aber wir fangen erst mal sanft an. Gordon Rybinski ist nicht in Berlin.
Ausnahmsweise sind wir heute früh nicht im politischen Berlin, sondern in Hamburg. Genauer gesagt an der Außenalster. Für diese extra Ausgabe habe ich dort Wolfgang Schmidt getroffen, der Kanzleramtsminister und einer der engsten Vertrauten von Olaf Scholz.
So, sie spazieren jetzt an diesen Alstergewässern entlang. Alle wissen ja über Außen-, Binnenalster und so weiter. Und wir hören so ein bisschen zu, es gibt Meta-Informationen. Es sind Männer, sie sind nicht die jüngsten und nicht die schlankesten. Was bedeutet? Spazieren ist nicht das Einfachste, was man machen kann. Spazieren und reden hört selbst.
Und das erleben eigentlich alle Regierungen. Und dann kommt das, was wir eben besprochen hatten hinzu, eine Dreierkonstellation, ist halt leider auch so, wie sie war, sehr streit anfällig. Und das heißt, wo wir vorhin drüber gesprochen hatten, ich sage, wir haben sehr, sehr viel geschafft. Sie sagen, wir gehen mal durch.
Wollen wir uns ganz kurz dahin lassen?
Sehr gerne.
Wir sind eine nicht erfolgreiche Regierung gewesen.
So.
Wäre das eine Idee, dass wir demnächst mal ein Salon aufnehmen? Du zu Hause, ich auf dem Cross-Trainer im Fitnessstudio?
Ja, bin ich dafür. Aber dann nur mit deinem Kameramann. Das wollen wir dann auch sehen. So, ich mache jetzt kurz Politikberatung und ich halte für sie für sehr wichtig. Wenn Gordon Rypinski sagt, wollen wir uns da mal hinsetzen? Nicht machen.
Denn das ist schon die freutsche Couch, meinst du?
Ich verbiete euch das. Macht das nicht. Ansonsten passiert das.
Jetzt haben wir uns hier mal einmal an die Alster gesetzt.
Schön, oder?
Weil es wirklich schön ist, aber weil es auch ein Ort ist, an dem man vielleicht ganz gut nachdenken könnte, an dem man, wenn man sich zu zweit unterhält, vielleicht auch mal ein tiefgehendes oder ein schwieriges Gespräch führen könnte.
Mit dem Kanzler als Minister.
Oder man könnte auch mal Händchen halten, also alles denkbar, ja.
Also ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen und ich... In welcher Reporter-Schule lernt man mit dem Kanzleramtsminister der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, während Trump und so weiter und Cree so zu reden?
Ja, aber ich war jetzt auch ein Bild bei Twitter zu sehen von von Brueger, der ein Interview führte, ich glaube mit Julia Klöckner. Und dieses Bild ging auch um, weil sie sich so gut verstanden, dass man eigentlich dachte, da haben die sich zum Stammtisch getroffen oder machen die ein Podcast. Also ich glaube daran zeigt sich aber sehr viel, nämlich dieses Verständnis der Journalisten für die Politiker, beziehungsweise man hat so den Eindruck, sie arbeiten zusammen an einem größeren Projekt, das uns allen dient, nachdem wir nicht jetzt unbedingt gefragt haben. Aber es scheint so zu sein, dass sie sich jetzt auch dann mal eben auf der gefühligen Ebene auch uns gegenüber öffnen, sich gegenüber öffnen. Aber dass das eigentlich so ein großes Miteinander ist. Also genau das Gegenteil eigentlich, was man ja von journalistischen Gesprächen erwartet, und von der Aufgabe des Journalisten, der ja nicht einfach nur so der gute Freund der Politiker sein sollte.
Ja, aber sie wollen, kennt man ja Podcasts als Buddy-Projekte, alle müssen miteinander gut klarkommen. Die Gesprächspartner seien es Politiker oder eben Kollegen, mit denen muss man sich gut verstehen. So, Gordon Rybinski weiß ja, dass wir alle knapp dran sind. Wir haben ja auch noch was zu tun. Also weiß er nicht, aber ich unterstelle es ihm so ein bisschen. Er hat ein besonderes Format, das 200-Sekunden-Interview. Bevor ihr euch fragt, was ist denn das schon wieder? Wir fangen einfach direkt mit der Meta-Analyse an, sonst macht das gar keinen Sinn. Also Gordon Rybinski erzählt jetzt selbst kurz vorm 200-Sekunden-Interview, aber über Bande einer Hörer-Nachricht.
Ein paar Mails und Kommentare habe ich herausgegriffen, stellvertretend. Seid nicht enttäuscht, wenn eurer jetzt nicht dabei ist. Wenn euch etwas ganz wichtiges, was noch nicht genannt ist, dann könnt ihr mir natürlich auch immer noch schreiben. Aber ein paar, die auch vielleicht was gesagt haben, was doppelt oder mehrfach kam, habe ich hier mal ausgesucht. Claudia zum Beispiel hat mir ein sehr ausführliches, sehr positives Feedback an, gerybinski at politico.eu geschickt. Vielen Dank dafür. Sie hat aber auch einen Kritikpunkt und zwar sagt sie, das 200-Sekunden-Interview wird jeden Tag wieder erklärt und das nervt sie so ein bisschen. Also insofern Claudia, wir haben das auch schon mal im Gefühl gehabt, wir erklären es jetzt ein bisschen weniger.
Wir können jetzt raten, ich stelle dir jetzt Quizfrage stellvertretend. Gordon Gerybinski ist also sehr hinterher, dir zu sagen, wann der Podcast beginnt, nämlich jetzt und dass du morgen ausschlafen kannst, weil er morgen nicht frei hat, aber im Regierungsflieger und so weiter. Was würdest du sagen ist das 200-Sekunden-Interview? Also was erklärt er da immer, was das bedeutet?
Könnte mir vorstellen, dass er erklärt hat, dass es 200 Sekunden lang ist.
Ja. Bingo. 100 Punkte. Nee, 200 Punkte. So, wir hören jetzt hier kurz Beatrix von Storch.
Frau von Storch war schon mal hier in dem Interview. Wir können gleich loslegen und die 200 Sekunden beginnen zu laufen, wenn ich meine erste Frage gestellt habe. Frau von Storch, ich grüße sie.
Ich grüße sie auch.
Ja, da hört man schon, sie ist nicht zum ersten Mal da. Sie kennt das schon. Er erklärt uns aber nochmal, sie war schon mal da. Also muss ich es ihr nicht erklären. Und dann sagt er trotzdem nochmal, dass die 200 Sekunden beginnen mit der ersten Frage. Also das ist für ganz blöde, wie die ganzen Podcasts.
Wie gesagt, das sind ja auch Leute, die haben ja Publikumsanalysen und sowas betrieben und kommen dann auf die Idee, dass man das so genau machen muss. Also ich meine, es wurde ja jetzt immer sehr viel gelacht darüber, ob das BSW so schlecht abgeschnitten hat, so die These von einigen BSW-Politikern, weil das BSW unter dem Knick auf dem Wahlzettel war, wenn man es aufmachte, dann kam das erst weiter unten. Und da haben dann sich wiederum viele darüber lustig gemacht, dass man das wirklich glauben kann, dass deshalb eine Wahl schlechter läuft für eine Partei. Wir hatten hier mal eine Folge, da haben wir gezeigt, wo Leute nach Rot oder Grün gehen sollten, wenn sie dieser oder jener politischen Ansicht war. Und selbst das war eine große Herausforderung für einige. Von daher kann ich mir das mit dem Knick sehr gut vorstellen, wenn man auch dann jeden Tag erzählen muss, was ein 200-Sekunden-Interview ist. Also alles ist denkbar.
Meine große Erkenntnis aus Athen ist, schon im Ursprung fand die Demokratie eigentlich im Theater des Dionysos statt und nicht auf der anderen Seite der Akropolis, in diesen ganzen parlamentischen Ratsgebäuden. Also da wo die Emotionen produziert wurden. Genau, da wo auch alle hinpassen, so großer Publikumsbetrieb. Also Beatrix von Storch war schon häufiger zu Gast, da redet Gordon Rybinski. Also einfach mit Nazis? Ja, aber er diskutiert das natürlich auch. Und bevor das hier so ein bisschen reflektiert, er hat auch Krah zu Gast. Von Krah wissen wir, der sitzt ja jetzt wieder im Bundestag, war aber vorher schon eine kontroverse Figur. Ich würde jetzt unabhängig davon, dass er von der AfD sagt, 200 Sekunden, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob man dafür, dass man sich mit dem Kampfsleramtsminister auf die Bank setzt, um mal durchzuschnaufen und jetzt ein tiefgründiges Gespräch. 200 Sekunden, ich glaub nicht so richtig dran, dass man da tiefgründig werden kann. Vor allem nicht über Telefon. Also ist es genau, wie man sich's vorstellt. Man redet mit Krah innerhalb von 200 Sekunden über die EU. Wir versuchen jetzt mal Spuren von Konstruktivität darin zu entdecken.
Die heutige EU ist furchtbar und muss weg, aber sie muss insgesamt weg. Wir brauchen einen Reset auf europäischer Ebene.
Aber Herr Krah, ganz kurz, Sie können ja nur für Deutschland Politik machen. Erstmal für Deutschland Ihre Erwartung Austritt?
Nein, Austritt heißt wir sind raus, die anderen bleiben drin, das will ich nicht. Ich möchte dieses Ding hier in Brüssel in der heutigen Form verschwindet und es kommt nachher was anderes, was besser zur Zeit passt.
Okay, weil im Programm steht, wir halten einen Austritt Deutschlands aus der Europäischen Union und dann die Gründung einer neuen Gemeinschaft für notwendig. Das heißt, dem schließen Sie sich nicht so ganz an, dem Programm?
Die neue Gemeinschaft, ja, aber das läuft mit Konsens, mit Partnern, das läuft nicht im Alleingang.
Also Krah will eine neue EU, aber die Alte auch nicht abräumen, was in seinem eigenen Wahlprogramm steht, interessiert ihn nicht. Er macht ja selber Politik.
Aber gut, dass wir mal drüber gesprochen haben.
Ja und Rypinski weist ihn nochmal drauf hin, dass er ja, wenn er sich im Bundestag wählen lässt, nur für Deutschland Politik machen kann. Also das ist sehr aufklärerisch. Jetzt fragen wir uns ein bisschen, ja aber ist es, also könnte man dann noch einfach sagen, ne wir reden jetzt nicht mit Leuten von der AfD, damit wir es zumindest in gewissen Korridoren konstruktiv halten. Stellt sich raus, wenn Gordon Rypinski mit Politikern über hochtrabende Themen redet, ist er einfach selber die AfD. Es hängt gar nicht vom Gesprächspartner ab. Hier zum Beispiel kleiner Auszug mit Ralf Stegner.
Also Verkehr muss man glaube ich haben. Das kann man ihnen einfach nicht überlassen. Die bauen nur Straßen in Bayern.
Ja, da kann man sich auch kurz, man hört das schon, 200 Sekunden um 16 Ministeriens-Posten auf 16 Personen zu verteilen. Nur darum ging es in diesem Gespräch.
So, also das geht nicht.
Und welches könnte man abgeben?
Also man könnte mal Entwicklungshilfe abgeben, wenn die daraus was machen würden.
Also das mal ausfüllen. Abschaffen.
Nö, nicht abschaffen.
Dass Resorbes bleiben?
Finde ich ja.
Ja, warum nicht abschaffen? Das ist auch eine schöne Idee.
Also abschaffen. Äh, nee, nicht abschaffen.
Ich frag mich ja die ganze Zeit, warum gehen da überhaupt Politiker hin? Also man hat doch auch nichts davon, wenn man da 200 Sekunden vorkommt, oder?
Doch. Du kannst was gewinnen. Wir hören das mal hier. Jetzt wird ein Gewinn vergeben nach Ende des Gesprächs.
Es geht doch darum zu sagen, wie...
Das ist übrigens Franziska Brandner, die neue Grünenchefin.
Schaffen wir es jetzt, dass Europa eine Stimme hat, dass wir gemeinsam hier die Ukraine stärken können und es nicht einen Diktatfrieden zwischen Putin und Trump gibt, an den die Europäer nichts zu tun haben und danach am Ende aber die zerstörte Europäische Union haben.
Frau Brandner, ich danke Ihnen herzlich. Eine extra Sekunde, aber die geben wir heute morgen großzügig aus. Vielen Dank. Danke schön. Schönen Tag.
Ja, das war die ganze Sekunde bekommen.
Ein schöner Erfolg. Ja, also das kann doch gar nicht sein, dass das jetzt der Journalismus ist. Ich meine, wir lästern über diese Pro Podcasts mit Joe Rogan, aber da sind ja selbst diese Gespräche noch vorzuziehen.
Wir hören hier Doro Behr. Sie bekommt jetzt auch Sekunden geschenkt. Wir hören uns an wie viele, stellen fest, könnte mehr sein. Und dann hören wir noch mal, wie sie sich dafür bedanken.
Das war recht schade der FDP.
Frau Behr, wir bleiben an dieser Stelle mit fünf Sekunden, die Sie gut haben für das nächste Interview.
Dankeschön.
Alles gut.
Also da kann sie sich schon freuen, wenn sie wiederkommt, bekommt sie noch fünf Sekunden mehr. Denn man weiß ja, Podcasts dürfen ja nur eine gewisse Kürze haben. Die dürfen ja nicht lang sein.
Es muss ganz kurz sein, außer man hat die AfD im Schlepptau, weil man macht ja gerne Access, Access Zugangsjournalismus. Man muss ja ganz nah dran sein. Dann kann man ja auch ausbrechen und aus den 200 Sekunden wieder einen ganzen Spaziergang machen mit der AfD-Leuten, um dann mit denen darüber zu reden, ob man jetzt das Entwicklungsministerium zum Beispiel abgibt.
Auf einen Punkt...
Abschafft natürlich.
Ich möchte gerne eingehen und zwar die Einordnung, warum wir eigentlich diese AfD-Interviews machen. Für mich waren da zwei Gründe ganz entscheidend. Der erste Grund ist, dass ich glaube, dass die AfD jetzt eine Größe erreicht hat, in der man sich journalistisch auf jeden Fall mit ihr auseinandersetzen muss und dass aus meiner Sicht auch das Argument nicht mehr zählt, dass man Extremisten womöglich Öffentlichkeit gibt und zwar, weil die AfD natürlich ihre eigene Öffentlichkeit hat über Telegram, über Social Media, gerade über TikTok und da natürlich ohne jede journalistische Standards einfach ihre Thesen raushaut und deswegen finde ich, muss die AfD journalistisch genauso herausgefordert werden wie alle anderen Parteien auch und deswegen nehme ich sie hier in die 200 Sekunden Interviews mit rein, in einem in aller Regel sehr engen Format. Ich würde übrigens auch Spaziergänge machen, das plan ich auch.
Ja, es gibt viele Rechte, die ja gerne Spaziergänge machen, wie wir wissen, gerade im Osten.
Genau, da sind Spaziergänge.
Da kann man auch mal mitgehen.
Ich komme auch zu Ihnen, in den Osten, in welchem Dorf wohnen Sie, da machen wir da einen Spaziergang.
Montags ist meistens gut.
Und dann reden wir darüber, welches Ministerium wir abschaffen. Also es sind die journalistischen Standards, die dazu führen, dass man sie in den eigenen Podcasts holt und nicht einfach machen lässt. Ich gucke auf die Uhr und stelle fest, wir können noch einen weiteren Blog hier rein machen, bevor wir den Karneval gucken. Die journalistischen Standards, wir bleiben bei Ripinski im Podcast. Der hat einen Gast.
Bröker.
Der Podcast ist von gestern, ist also noch ganz frisch.
Also das ist ja das Twitch-Prinzip. Ja, also das ist ja so wie die Twitch-Stream, man hat da Monte, man hat Knossi und und und. Und dann müssen die sich die ganze Zeit abends gegenseitig einladen, reißen Pokemon-Karten auf, saufen Eistee und dann reden sie irgendein Kram. Und dann erhöhen sie sich so gegenseitig die Reichweite. Und so funktioniert das hier auch.
Nicht ganz, denn du hast vergessen, hier sind ja journalistische Standards.
Ja, natürlich.
Das überprüfen wir jetzt an dem Gespräch gestern. Im Verlauf der Clips könnt ihr euch die Frage stellen, wie lang ging dieser Podcast, ich sag's euch, 38 Minuten. Also sehr lang ist es nicht. Trotzdem kriegt man einiges unter in so einem journalistischen Podcast. Wir hören uns das mal an. Also Inhalte und journalistische Standards. Erst mal sehen wir natürlich nichts davon am Anfang. Es ist ja ein lockerer Einstieg. Wir hören aber ein weiteres Twitch-Prinzip.
Es ist also Zeit für eine kräftige Analyse. Und mit wem könnte ich die besser bestreiten als mit Michael Brueckert? Mit meinem früheren Podcast-Partner, mit dem Chefredakteur von Table Briefings, mit dem ich ja die eine oder andere Meinungsverschiedenheit eigentlich immer habe. Und doch nähern wir uns den großen Fachfragen und davon gibt es ja genug in dieser Zeit.
Ist im Prinzip wie bei uns, oder?
Beef.
Ja.
Suchst ja ja niemanden raus.
Du bist ja auch eher Team Luhmann, ich eher Team Frankfurter Schule und so. Das sind ja wahrscheinlich ähnliche Konflikte, die die da austragen.
Genau. Ja. Wir hören uns das mal an. Zuerst träumen sie von großer Zweisamkeit gemeinsam.
Aber beim nächsten Mal nehmen wir den live miteinander auf und dann habe ich auch ein Glas Wein.
Gut, denke ich.
Ja.
Das machen wir mal wieder.
Unbedingt mal wieder zusammen live auftreten.
So.
Vor allen der Applausometer war ja damals schon immer eindeutig verteilt. Insofern ja, würde ich mich sehr freuen.
In Köln für dich, in Hannover für mich. Ideen für die Location, gerepinski at politico.eu.
Ja, ein kleiner höheres Service. Es wird schon mal der Wunsch geäußert, gibt uns doch mal eine Location und so weiter. Wir sagen jetzt nicht, kommt auf keinen Fall in die Caste, das ist hier ein heiliger Ort, darf nicht entweid werden. So wir hören jetzt, okay, sie treffen sich, sie wollen streiten, sie kündigen das an.
Also die Grünen sind im Moment die fiskalpolitischen Falken in diesem Land und damit nah bei mir.
Michael, oder man könnte es auch anders nennen, Britta Hasselmann, Katharina Dröge oder wie wir es nennen CDU-Pur.
So ist das. Siehst du, du siehst es am Ende wieder genau wie ich.
Es ist ja auch das Faktisch Richtige.
Es ist faktisch so blödsinnig, wenn man es dann mal noch eins weiter dreht, weil mit CDU-Pur hat das natürlich nichts zu tun. Und das Taktieren der Grünen war ja eines, das darauf abzielte, dass man 100 Milliarden Klima rein verhandelt bekommt. Warum die sich immer wieder dann dabei auf die Mütter rennt und so kapriziert, habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden. Und dann so eine australisiertspolitische Vernunft walten diesen, die sie ja in Wahrheit selbst nicht geglaubt haben. Aber zu interpretieren, dass dies jetzt eigentlich eine grüne Kehrtwende Richtung CDU ist, was Finanzpolitik anbelangt, ist doch ein bisschen schief, scheint mir.
Finde ich erstaunlich, dass du jetzt nach 20 Clips immer noch Spuren politischen, inhaltlichen Interessen hast.
Das ist ein völlig falsches Modus, tut mir leid.
Ich hab nur noch gehört, dass da gar kein Beef ist, die haben doch Beef versprochen, aber stattdessen sind sie irgendwie die ganze Zeit einer Meinung.
Merz hätte zugleich ein Zeichen geben können in Richtung Rot und Grün, dass man auf Zusammenarbeit bedacht ist und er hätte bei dieser Wahl wahrscheinlich keinen Prozentpunkt weniger bekommen und hätte eine viel einfache Position danach gehabt, verstehe ich nicht.
Gordon, ich muss dir wieder einmal, das ist beim letzten Podcast ja auch schon passiert, mit dir zustimmen.
Wo ist mein Beef? Hier vielleicht.
Es ist ja auch so, auch du nimmst ja von einem Podcast mit mir was mit, was du vielleicht gestern noch nicht gedacht hast. Nehmen wir mal an.
Das werden wir nochmal sehen. Das werden wir nochmal sehen. Das wage ich zu bezweifeln. Ich bin da sehr bedacht. Ich bin da immer noch hoffnungsfroh.
Auf jeden Fall die Frage bei Friedrich Merz ist doch, was ist wirklich sein Kompass? Das ist ja die Frage.
Ja, genau. So wir hören jetzt noch so ein bisschen Merz. Also es kann jetzt wieder Spuren von Inhalt enthalten. Und danach stellen sie wieder fest, ob sie sich jetzt streiten oder nicht. Wenn sie sich nicht streiten, muss das ja vorher, was gesagt wurde, unstreitbar gewesen sein, unstrittig. Aber es ist ganz wirr. Also wir würden sofort in diesen Podcast reinspringen und denen zeigen, was Beef ist. Stattdessen feuern sie das inhaltlich ab und sagen danach, ja ja, genau.
Aber da lässt er sich vom politischen System ein Stück weit aufessen. Und da finde ich, hat er sich noch nicht entschieden, was für eine Art Kanzler er sein will.
Ich glaube, er ist ein Angela Merkel mit Bosbach-Rhetorik. Er sieht jetzt schon, welche Kompromisse man in diesem Land eingehen muss, wie man mit den Sozialdemokraten umgehen muss, Klammer auf, leider bei bestimmten Themen wird es sonst in diesem Land keine Mehrheiten geben und macht aber die Hardliner-Rhetorik, wie ein Wolfgang Bosbach zu seinen besten Zeiten.
Das mag ich. Das mag ich wirklich. Das ist ein schönes Bild. Angela Merkel mit Bosbach-Rhetorik. Hast du das schon mal gesagt?
Nee, mir fällt bei dir viel sehr spontan ein.
Ja gut, weil ich dich inspiriere.
Unter anderem.
Wahnsinnsanalyse.
Hier noch so ein bisschen. Wir sehen natürlich auch, dass Essen kulinarische Leute sind. Und es geht ja auch gerade um Steuerermäßigung für Gastro und so.
Und ich möchte einfach nur fürs Protokoll sagen, dass du innerhalb von zwei Minuten gerade dich lustig gemacht hast über meine kulinarischen Geschichten und dann tatsächlich eine kulinarische Geschichte bei dir selbst angeteasert hast. Ist okay. Ist okay. Du kannst das gerne so machen. Jeder wie er will.
Das ist der Beef, der uns versprochen wurde. Dass es Anlässe für Beef gibt, das hören wir mal hier.
Natürlich ist Johannes Vogel ein...
Sie gehen so ein paar FDP-Namen durch, denen Sie jetzt so eine Träne hinterherweinen, weil die Fraktion nicht mehr da ist. Alles an Christian Lindner gescheitert, obwohl es doch da so viele gute Leute gab. Welche zum Beispiel?
Ein großartiger Sozialpolitiker und diese Stimme, wie er Sozialstaat denkt, finde ich würde auch fehlen, wenn in einem Parlament nur noch Linke, Grüne und AfD sind. Es gibt viele kluge Liberale, aber ich brauche manchmal auch eine Prise echten Wirtschaftsliberalismus a la Frank Schäffler. Zumindest möchte ich zur Denkraumerweiterung meiner Argumentation diesen Mann im Parlament hören. Also da fehlt was, Gordon.
Denkraumerweiterung mit Frank Schäffler, da muss man auch erst mal drauf kommen. Auf diese eigene Denkraumerweiterung, die einen dazu führt. Und ja, Frank Schäffler ist jemand, der den libertären Geist und Einrennt und all das hochhält, der das leider intellektuell nicht fundiert tun kann, aber er ist eine Stimme, die den Denkraumerweiter hat. Was wir ja hier nochmal so wunderbar sehen ist, dass über diese Politik, von der diese Leute ja in dem Sinne nicht betroffen sind, weil sie genügend verdienen, sie müssen nicht jetzt Angst haben, dass 100 Euro mehr oder weniger am Potmanet sind, dass sich dadurch etwas verändert, dass diese die Politik ja einfach so beobachten, wie andere sich eine Daily Soap ansehen und sagen auch schade, dass Max nicht mehr dabei ist und wurde jetzt gegen Dennis ausgetauscht oder so. Ja, also das ist GZSZ nur mit echten Leuten sehen wir hier und so wird das Ganze rezipiert und jetzt fragt man sich, ob die Show noch so gut sein wird und wenn sie dann nicht mehr so gut ist, dann hat das natürlich auch Auswirkungen auf die Show, die Repinsky und Bröker machen. Denn sie brauchen ja diese Show, um wiederum ihre Show daran anzudocken. Und daran kann man eigentlich sehen, dass diese Podcasts, die ihr eigentlich zur Vertiefung einladen würden, denn 38 Minuten sagst du sei jetzt nicht so lang, aber ist es eigentlich schon ziemlich lang, um fundiert über etwas zu sprechen. Und dass genau dies aber nicht eingelöst wird und dass man auch damit wirklich die politische Debattenkultur, die eigentlich durch Podcasts ermöglicht würde, völlig negiert und das ist ja das große Problem all dieser täglich erscheinenden Podcasts, dass sie wirklich wieder das dümmstmögliche aus einem an sich revolutionären Medium machen. Man erinnere sich daran, dass ja auch das Fernsehen, wenn man sich einzelne Dinge mal bei YouTube nochmal abruft, tatsächlich experimentelles Großes herstellen konnte. Und auch da hat man sich dann entschieden, das dümmstmögliche zu machen. Das heißt, fünf Politiker, die sich mehr oder weniger vertragen, zusammenzusetzen und einen dazu zu nehmen, den alle nicht mögen. Und dann heißt das politische Talkshow. Und an dem Punkt sind wir ja eigentlich jetzt angekommen. Und dann ist es alles nur noch der Modus der Unterhaltung, bei aber dann immer wieder gleichzeitiger staatspolitischer Verantwortung, die herauf beschworen wird. Aber das ist ja eine permanente Kluft, die da ist. Also zwischen dem Sprechen über Politik und dann wieder so großen Ordnungsrufen. Wir retten gerade die Demokratie, wir müssen wehrhaft werden etc.
Wenn du das Fernsehen sagst, eigentlich ist jetzt auch in dieser Podcastlandschaft der Moment, wo man bei einem politischen Gespräch, wenn bestimmte Sätze fallen, wie zum Beispiel mir fehlt Frank Scheffler für die Denkraum Erweiterung, dann einfach sagt, oh ich habe eine Axt mitgebracht, ich haue jetzt diesen Tisch.
Ganz richtig.
Eigentlich ist dieser Moment jetzt für die Podcastwelt. Mal gucken, wer demnächst Äxte dabei hat. Otto Fricke, 38 Minuten, die FDP nicht mehr da, man muss noch so ein paar Tränen vergießen.
Ich hätte auch sofort an Otto Fricke gedacht, der einfach eine Bereicherung ist für die Politik, das muss man einfach sagen, in der Leichtigkeit und Ernsthaftigkeit zugleich, mit der er sich zum Beispiel mit Haushaltsthemen auseinandersetzt, das finde ich wirklich.
Haushaltsthemen, was wäre Haushaltsthemen?
Außerdem ist er Lakritz-Fan, wie ich gelernt habe. Absolut richtig. In seinem Büro, er hat da so richtige Lakritz-Sammlung, wie wir beide ja auch, können wir einfach mal so sagen. Wahrscheinlich der kontroverseste Satz, den wir hier in diesem Podcast sagen.
Ja, aber du weißt ja, warum Gott.
Wegen Niederlande.
Ja, das auch, aber wir hatten doch schon mal das in unserem früheren gemeinsamen Podcast, dass wir in diesem Podcast exzessiv Katjes gelobt haben. Ein Unternehmen im Wahlkreis von Otto Fricke, ein großartiges Unternehmen. Ja, in Emmerich am Niederrhein.
Also heute habt ihr alle was gelernt. Katjes ist im Wahlkreis von Otto Fricke, der aber nicht mehr im Bundestag ist. Wer so viel Lakritz ist, muss auch Sport machen.
Oliver Luksic hat das 1 zu 0 geschossen. Ich hab.
Bei welchem Spiel? Ah ja, die Wortspieler gegen den FC Bundestag.
Er hat's. Ja, ja, ich hab noch versucht ihn mit einer Grätsche.
Ich hab doch gerade gesagt, das eine Tor kann ja sein.
Aber es war das eine Tor war da. Aber es war das 1 zu 0.
Und die drei anderen? Also nee.
Die drei anderen, die gab es nicht mehr. Es gab dann nur noch acht.
Es gab nur die einen, der drei gemacht hat, glaube ich, bei den Wortspielern. Aber ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Ja, das ist ganz toll, Michael. Michael Bröker hat die drei Tore gemacht. Wir gönnen dir das. Danke.
Dann allerdings fiel die dritte Halbzeit aus. Sie leiten noch heute.
Ja, aber kannst du mal bitte deine Kontakte zu den Sozialdemokraten mal aktivieren und Mahmoud Özdemir endlich dazu bringen, dass er zu diesem Rückspiel kommt, was er nie gemacht hat?
Ja, und das habe ich letztens gemacht, als ich ihn in der Kantine des Bundestags getroffen habe. Staatssekretär, parlamentarischer Staatssekretär im Innenministerium, Mahmoud Özdemir, den ich gefragt habe, wann kommt es endlich zu dem Rückspiel? Ich habe das dann verbunden mit einem Satz wie da trauen sich die Kicker des FC Bundestag wohl nicht. Daraufhin hat er gesagt, dass du lieber Michael, dein Versprechen nicht eingehalten hast, nämlich für die dritte Halbzeit zu sorgen.
Achso, woran lag das damals schon?
Du wolltest was organisieren, wo die dritte Halbzeit stattfindet und das hast du nicht gemacht.
Achso, da hat Karl-Heinz Steingart das Schiff nicht hergegeben.
Das war der Grund. Das wurde dir bis heute, ich sag jetzt mal, wirst du jetzt ein Angebot ausgeben?
Tablecafé.
Ja, ich hätte sonst gesagt Journalistenclub.
Also beides eher gute Locationen. Pass auf, wir machen folgendes Gordon, wir machen, wenn wir uns das nächste Mal persönlich sehen, machen wir Schnick Schnack Schnuck für die Location und der andere macht das Catering.
Man sehnt sich doch vielleicht zurück, als noch alles linear war. Man konnte eben nur drei Minuten haben, wenn man etwas als Journalist zu sagen hatte im Radio, denn danach kam ein anderer Kollege und hat übernommen. Oder bei der Zeitung gab es eben eine Zeilenbegrenzung. Es hatte vielleicht doch alles seinen Sinn, zeigt sich.
Ja.
Das heißt, du schließt jetzt mit diesem Podcast ab. Das heißt, wie stelle ich mir jetzt den Montag danach, also den nächsten Montag von Stefan vor? Was hörst du dir dann an morgens?
Mal sehen, das hört ihr dann am Ende des Monats. Es wird wahrscheinlich ein wahnsinnig kluger Podcast.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Aber du deabonnierst jetzt.
Ja. Ich glaube, ich hab alles gehört. Und ich glaube, ihr auch bis hierhin. Aber wir hören diese Folge von gestern noch zu Ende. Denn jetzt, Achtung, es wird inhaltlich für uns interessant. Wir interessieren uns ja für weite Denkräume, in denen spielen die Linken eine Rolle, weil sie angeblich unter der 5 Prozent, ach nee doch nicht, 8, so und so und jetzt 10. Wie ist die Analyse der beiden zur Linken?
Ich bin überrascht. Ich hatte es auch nicht kommen sehen. Ich habe es völlig fehl eingeschätzt. Die Geschichte mit der Linkspartei. Aber auch sie haben natürlich ihre Berechtigung im Parlament, weil sie gerade auch bei den jungen Leuten offenbar eine Sehnsucht erfüllt haben.
Ja, das ist so. Auf jeden Fall.
Ja, da kann man ja dankbar sein. Es erlaubt es, dass sie drin sind. Im Übrigen, das darf ich schon vorwegnehmen, wenn wir uns gleich mit einer Karnevalssitzung beschäftigen werden. Dort kamen vier Stunden, obwohl es die ganze Zeit um Politik ging, die Linkspartei kein einziges Mal vor. Und das war einige Tage nach der Wahl, also man hatte dieses Ergebnis bereits.
Ja, aber vielleicht kamen Katzen vor?
Lieber Michael, bevor du jetzt gleich hier diesen Podcast wieder verlässt, müssen wir noch einige private Worte wechseln, nur ganz kurz einmal. Ich hoffe, du kannst mir bestätigen, dass es dir gut geht. Ich sehe dich ja nicht mehr so häufig.
Mir geht es gut Gordon, ich bin sehr entspannt, innerlich relaxed und guten Mutes.
Ja, und ich habe gesehen, du hast jetzt Katzenbabys auf der Brust. Nicht einen Hund, aber Katzenbabys.
Ich habe mich erfolgreich gegen Hunde gewehrt und musste Katzen akzeptieren.
Ja, ein Clip schaffen wir noch. Das Finale dieses tollen Podcasts, also Minute 38 oder so.
Lieber Michael, es war mir eine große Freude mit dir, diesen Wochenrückblick und Vorausschau für die nächste Woche und für die nächsten Wochen zu vollziehen. Es war eine große Freude, du hast mich inspiriert. Du hast mich bereichert und diesen Podcast und meine Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer auch. Ich glaube, du hast einige auch wieder sehr glücklich gemacht, weil du hier warst. Bist du auch ein bisschen glücklich?
Ja, absolut. Vielen Dank, Herr Gordon.
Das ist schön. Und wir haben ein paar Impulse, an denen wir, glaube ich, anknüpfen sollten, nämlich das nächste Mal, wenn wir uns treffen, dann trinken wir ein Glas Wein miteinander und nehmen diesen Podcast auf und außerdem gehen wir die Sache mit den Wortspielern nochmal an. Das ist doch, also haben wir echte Pläne. Find ich gut. Unbedingt. Michael, ich wünsche dir das Liebe, ein schönes Wochenende. Ich bin gespannt auf deine kulinarische Geschichte.
Ciao, ciao. Das Problem ist, glaube ich, dass sie sich mit Thomas Gottschalk verwechseln. Also Thomas Gottschalk funktioniert ja nur über solche Dinge. Also Thomas Gottschalk funktioniert ja im Fernsehen oder auch ein paar andere solche Moderatoren funktionieren ja eben nur darüber, dass sie wo eingeladen werden, erzählen irgendwas vom Rotwein oder dass sie mal Fußball gespielt haben. Und dann war das der Auftritt und dadurch, wie sie das machen, ist es für das Publikum unterhaltsam. Sobald diese Leute dann anfangen, wir haben es bei Thomas Gottschalk gesehen, dann auch über Politik zu reden, geht das daneben. Die gehen jetzt den umgekehrten Weg. Wir reden immer über Politik, aber versuchen mal Thomas Gottschalk zu spielen, geht natürlich auch daneben.
Also ich erspare uns den Rest für heute. Zwei, also den alles Mühe kommt nicht mehr zu Ohr, außer ich tease an für Ende des Monats, wenn wir es da unterkriegen. Robin Alexander sagt bei uns im Podcast, wir werden weniger Meinung, wir werden immer mehr erklären, das überprüfen wir dann mal. Und wie man heute Werbung macht unter dem Deckmandel des politischen Engagements, der Chef von Bitpanda war bei Michael Bröker zu Gast, der darunter leidet, dass die FDP aus dem Bundestag geflogen ist und die Linke, was war denn da los? Da kann man sich schon mal fragen, wie kann denn das Gespräch gestaltet werden? Aber jetzt, keine Wahl.
Ja, es ist eine sehr eigenartige Situation, denn ich bringe diese Clips mit, beziehungsweise haben sie denn gestern digital Stefan geschickt, worauf er gleich sagt, ja der Auftritt von Reichow war ganz gut. Und ich dachte wie, ich bringe ihm jetzt Mainz bleibt Mainz, wie singt und lacht mit und Stefan hat das gesehen und reagiert gleich darauf. Ich dachte, ich müsste jetzt hier erstmal ausführlich erzählen, dass es diese Fernsehsitzung gibt. Aber nein, Stefan, du hast sie gesehen.
Ja.
Warum?
Zum einen Reichow ist auch hier in der Kässe zu Gast im November.
Jaja, also der ist über den Karneval hinaus bekannt. Aber dass du das wusstest, dass der da ist.
Ich hab mir schon mal Tickets geholt, falls jemand hier Reichow ist. Aber da kommen wir ja zum Ende drauf. Also meine Tochter ist 14 und sie interessiert sich für Politik. Wir schauen also Tagesschau. Und nach der Tagesschau kam die Sendung. Und da sie eine Gardetänzerin ist, weil wir ja auch Karneval haben hier Fasching in Frankfurt, haben wir diesen Rheinland-Pfälzischen Karneval geguckt und haben gesagt, wir gucken jetzt so lange bis ein Gardetanz kommt. Und den schauen wir uns dann an. Nur es gibt da gar keinen Gardetanz.
Ja, es wird ein bisschen getanzt, aber eben nicht in der klassischen Gardetanz. Da musst du in eine Kölsch-Sitzung gucken.
Ja, wir haben dann noch mal die hessische, die war natürlich super langweilig, aber dafür gab es dann Wiesbadener Gardetanz.
Also die Mainze war auch super langweilig, aber in einer anderen Hinsicht, ja. Wir beginnen mal, also Mainz bleibt Mainz heißt diese Sendung Mainz weiß Mainz wie es singt und lacht. Da sind auch zwei Titel zusammengeschoben, sagen manche jetzt zurecht, ja. Früher gab es sogar mal beide Sitzungen Mainz bleibt Mainz und Mainz wie es singt und lacht im Fernsehen in der ARD ausgestaltet. Jetzt nur noch diese eine Sendung seit vielen, vielen Jahren, die dauert vier Stunden, wird immer freitags an Karneval, das war der 28. Februar, ausgestaltet und ist dann quasi der große Auftakt zu dem, was dann Rosenmontag in Mainz folgt. Diese Mainzer Sitzung hören wir uns jetzt an. Wir sehen uns keine Gardetänze an und sonstige Einlagen, sondern wir hören uns an, was dort so geredet wurde in der Bütte. Denn Mainzer Fastnacht ist, Fastnacht sagt man ja da, ist sehr politisch, will es auch sein. Politiker sind anwesend im Saal und man kann hier ganz gut erfahren, wieso das, was man die Mitte nennt, zu der sich dann Friedrich Merz zählt, Julia Klöckner und und und, wie diese Mitte so tickt. Wir hören mal rein.
Holden, Herrinnen, holden, nachlesen, ich begrüße Sie recht herzlich zur Fernsehsitzung Mainz bleibt Mainz wie es singt und lacht 2025.
Es hat auch ein schöner Stil, so zu sprechen, oder? Wir müssen mal den ganzen Podcast über machen.
Ja, aber für so einen männlichen Sopran hat er auch so einen Körper dazu. Also das passt alles schon zu sprechen.
Ein sehr stattlicher Mann, ganz richtig. Erster Auftritt, sehr häufig der Till, Till-Eulenspiel. Es kommt jemand in einem solchen Gewand auf die Bühne und liest uns der politischen Öffentlichkeit die Leviten.
Wie man den Wahlkampf dreht und wendet, was bin ich froh, dass der jetzt endet. Das denkt sich sicher gar nicht eitel. Inzwischen auch Alice Weidel. Sie kandidierte, das macht Sinn, als Reichskanzlerin, Entschuldigung, Bundeskanzlerin.
Muss man erklären für die Leute, die nicht aus Mähens sind, wenn Witze gemacht werden, die so hart an der Grenze sind, wir haben schon gehört, hier wagt sich jemand weit vor, dann gibt es so ein Hohoho-Lachen und die ersten fangen an zu singen, uiuiuiuiuiuiuiui auauauauauauau und dann setzt das Orchester dazu ein. Auch um das dann abzukürzen, damit das Publikum nicht ganz ausrastet und Minuten lang das tut. Denn da gibt es ja auch legendäre Mainzer Sitzungen. Also Ernst Nezscher hat in den 60er Jahren Heile Heile Gänz hier gesungen, es wird bald wieder gut und die Menschen haben angefangen zu weinen. Oder bei Humber Humber Tete Rehm musste 20 Minuten überzogen werden, weil die Leute auch da nicht mehr auf ihre Plätze zurück kamen. Also man muss versuchen, das Dionysische, wir haben heute schon von gesprochen, immer wieder auch in ein Korsett zu schnüren.
Wenn das so weitergeht, tauschen wir heute einfach nur in unserer Hörerschaft aus. Keiner hört mehr politische Podcasts, aber dafür nächstes Jahr alle gucken, meins bleibt meins.
Also ich wollte eigentlich das Gegenteil hier machen, wollte noch mal ganz klar die abschreckende Seite zeigen, aber vielleicht geht es auch dabei. Naja, also der Humor richtet sich natürlich nicht nur gegen die AfD.
Auch er wollte gern den Kanzler machen. Robert Habeck. Ja und jetzt nicht lache. Warum auch nicht, so frag ich dann, ist doch egal, bei diesem Mann, in welchem Amte der Artist fachlich überfordert ist.
Robert Habeck kommt nicht einmal vor, nicht zweimal, sondern wie wir merken noch sehr häufig, zum Beispiel gleich wieder.
Stattdessen war er gelb des Wister unser Bundeswirtschaftsminister und als solcher könnte man dran denke, den Strompreis für die Wirtschaft senke. Doch da macht der Robert sich nichts draus. Teurer Strom macht ihm nichts aus, weil er ihn selber gar nicht bräuchte. Er ist ja schließlich keine Leuchte.
Also Robert Habeck tut mir inzwischen auch sehr leid.
Man konstituiert sich nochmal in seinen Bürgertum, indem man diese Witze dort abfährt.
Wir haben zu viel Michael Bruegel gehört.
Ja, wir können jetzt ja denken, da ist ja so ein bisschen was im Januar, Februar passiert mit Friedrich Merz. Dann gibt es ja vielleicht das ein oder andere, was man aufs Korn nehmen könnte, wenn man in der Bütt steht.
Doch jetzt hat der Friedrich sich ungallant an der Brandmauer die Finger verbrannt.
Oha, was passiert jetzt?
Zerschepperte viel Porzellan und das rief Mutti auf den Plan. Die heilige Angela, ihr Liebeleid vom Orden der Alternativlosigkeit. Gibt Vorschläge dem März jetzt satt für Probleme, die sie verursacht hat.
Also die CDU ist überhaupt nicht das Problem. Merkel ist das Problem und natürlich die AfD.
Du darfst frustriert sein, wenn in Deutschland in Kürze die nächsten Verkehrsbrücken werden einstürze. Du darfst frustriert sein, wenn Menschen auf Erden Opfer von völlig Bekloppten werden. Doch all dieser Frust kannst du mir nicht erzähle. Berechtigt dazu, diese braune Michpoke zu wähle.
Das Publikum steht dann dabei auf, es gibt dann ewig Standing Ovation, das Orchester spielt, alle sind außer Rand und Band. So Szenen werden sich mehrmals wiederholen. Wir werden aber nicht eine Kritik an der CDU vorfinden, sondern des Problems nach wie vor die AfD. Sonst haben sich alle eigentlich korrekt verhalten, außer natürlich Habeck, der diese komische Wirtschaftspolitik gemacht hat.
Ich will noch eine Beobachtung zur Haltungsnote schildern. Ist mir schon aufgefallen, als ich es im Fernsehen sah, hier hat niemand einen Freund, der das mal durch GPT jagen könnte, damit der Reim und der Satzbau hinhauen.
Ja, noch mal zum Schluss erfahren wir.
Narrenfreiheit immerfort heißt Freiheit am gesprochenen Wort und dieser Freiheitsgarantie ist und bleibt Demokratie. Drum glaubt und kämpft um unsere Staatsformen. Sie ist empfindlich wie ein Saatkorn. Ein Mensch wie Putin gedeiht nur in einer echten Diktatur. Die Wahl vom Sonntag machte klar, Freiheit ist kein Accessoire. Ob BSW, ob AfD, ob Linke oder Rechte, es bleiben Putins Wagenknechte. Drum lasst euch drauf vereidigte, die Freiheit zu verteidige.
Ja, also die Probleme sind benannt. BSW, AfD, Hufeisen links rechts und sonst ist die gesunde Mitte weiterhin wohl anständig. Das lädt uns einmal kurz zu entspannen bei einem Tänzchen. Ja, Rukizuki. Kennst du Rukizuki? Muss man auch leider sagen, Mehns hat seit etwa 60 Jahren keine neuen Lieder hervorgebracht, die irgendwie nennenswert sind.
Da steh ich ja drauf.
Also es ist interessant, es gibt immer wieder irgendwelche musikalischen Einladen, das kann man wirklich nicht aushalten und es geht dann immer nur mit diesen alten Liedern. Hier Rukizuki, das linke Beinche vor und wieder zurück, das rechte Beinche vor, das ist der ganze Trick. Wir tanzen Rukizuki und drehen uns dabei um. Das Spielchen ist nicht dumm.
Das können die jetzt von mir aus 2500 Jahre machen, dann triggere ich dahin und sage, das war der Moment.
Wie zu den alten Griechen. Meinungsfreiheit ist ein großes Thema natürlich im Karneval, die Narrenfreiheit, wir haben es schon gehört. Da gibt es jetzt eine Figur, die als Polizist auftritt und auch über die Meinungsfreiheit spricht. Würde ich sagen, da hat jemand auch nicht nur Gordon Rapinski gehört, sondern vielleicht auch schon ein paar andere Formate, ein paar andere Ableger, Formate von Springer oder auch ehemals Springerleuten, die jetzt woanders runtergekommen sind, gehört.
Wobei als Beamter, das ist zu beklaren, darfst du manche Begriffe heute gar nicht mehr sagen. Zum Gassebub hat man ein Spangett gesagt. Heute kommt gleich sein Vater und du wirst verklagt. Mal ganz repet war von Mänserbegriffe muss ich Polizei diplomatisch umschiffen. Dolbore, Spitzklicke, so leid hatte ich täglich. Zigeune, Indianer, ist heute nicht mehr möglich. Auch Bagage, dieses Mänser-Watt steht in Frage, nur Schiffschaukelbremse, das darfste noch sagen.
Da frag ich mich, Indianer ist ein Mänserbegriff, war mir auch neu.
Das sind übrigens die Leute, die Ole dann in der Diskussion Wohlstandsverwahrlosung vorwerfen.
Ja.
Stefan, du hast mir mal gesagt, du bist ein großer Fan von Halloween, weil du sagst, das kann man feiern, ohne diese Tradition mit sich rumzuschleppen. Das sei einfach so ein sehr angenehmes Fest, das ist nicht überladen mit irgendwelchen Erwartungen, die Familie müssen sich nicht schon vorher drei Wochen zerstreiten, um es zu händeln und dann auch noch mal währenddessen, sondern man kann es einfach so begehen, sagst du.
Es ist wahnsinnig überladen, aber niemand kriegt Geschenke, niemand wird gefragt, was schenkst du, was kaufst du und so weiter und so fort, der ganze Kram, sondern es ist einfach eine gewisse Stimmung und meistens geht man ja auch dahin.
Weil hier eigentlich gar nicht die Tradition ist, sagst du, kann man es eigentlich entspannter händeln. Dieser schon erwähnte Polizist sieht das anders, aber ich habe auch seinen Punkt nicht so ganz verstanden, muss ich zugeben, vielleicht können welche ihr helfen.
Neigt sich das Jahr so ins allerletzte Drittel, beginnt polizeilich ein dunkles Kapitel. Früher dachten wir an Herbstlaub oder auch Ende Dank. Heute feiert man Halloween. Das ist doch krank. Manch Straße, die putzt man zur Geisterbahn raus. Na ja, in Mainz gibt es auch Zonen, die sehen immer so aus. Man denkt oft der Kürbiskopf zeigt ihr Gespenster. Dabei guckt die Nachbarin selbst aus dem Fenster.
Aber was ist jetzt das Unbehagen mit Halloween?
Keine Ahnung. In meiner Kindheit gab es nicht so ein Kram. Wahrscheinlich waren wir in dem Mond noch daheim. Wir spielten noch Clique auf Straße und Gasse. Im Fernsehen gab es Flippe. Das fanden wir klasse. Und wurdest du älter, hast die Mädels im Blick. Gab es keine Handybilder von uns, war es ein Clique. Mir brauchte kein WhatsApp und Red Bull in Dose. Mit Apfelkorn, Pessico, begann unsere Show.
Ja, früher war alles besser mit Apfelkorn.
Das macht Europa wieder groß.
Ja, ganz klar. Es gibt wenige Frauen in der Mehnsafasnacht-Sitzung. Es kommt dann einer auf die Bühne und zwar spielt diese eine Erzieherin. Und man denkt, aha, der Sitzungspräsident leitet mal ein.
Einige Berufsgruppen in unserem Land haben es ja wirklich nicht leicht. Ich denke dabei zum Beispiel an die Erzieherinnen. Große Verantwortung, aber kleines Salär. Und deshalb haben wir eine Dame zu uns gebeten, die sich hier bestens auskennt.
Da wird schon mitgeklatscht. Das ist der Main seiner Hallermarsch.
Genau. Jetzt kommt aber was, was ich gut fand, als ich sah. Ich bin gespannt, wie...
Ja, ich fand vor allem den Auftakt gut.
Ja, als Erzieherin, da hat man es schwer. Die Kitas voll, die Kassen leer. Drum steh ich hier und will euch sagen, das ist so kaum noch zu ertraren. Es muss ich tun, was auf der Welt. Und ich, ich möchte eins, mehr Geld.
Aber es geht wie folgt weiter.
Also, entschuldige, wenn ich mal unterbrechen muss, aber ich hab gerade eine Meldung reinbekommen. Es haben dich noch einige Ehrengäste angekündigt und die haben wenig Zeit und die wollen unbedingt jetzt noch schnell auf die Bühne. Ich begrüße frisch aus Berlin eingetroffen Olaf Scholz, Robert Habeck, Friedrich Metz, Alice Weidel, Christian Lindner und Sarah Wagenknecht.
Was geschieht hier? Es kommen jetzt einige Schauspieler auf die Bühne, die so ein bisschen so aussehen wie die genannten Spitzenpolitiker und die müssen jetzt von der Erzieherin betreut werden. Ich fand es so mittelgut, jetzt habe ich aber gerade diese ganzen Clips aus dem Politik-Podcast gehört und dachte dann jetzt wieder, nee eigentlich ist das vielleicht das Richtige dann auch gleich so mit Politikern umzugehen und das Ganze so zu thematisieren. Denn eigentlich ist das die adäquateste Lösung, die sich anbietet. Das führt dann zum Beispiel zu solchen Proanten. Also die Erzieherin kann nun jetzt nicht mehr weiter dort in den Klassenkampf gehen, sondern muss sich kümmern.
Ein Begrüßungskreis zusammen, ja? Sollen wir das machen? Ja. Robert, Robert leg doch bitte mal das Handy weg. Robert, komm, da ist doch auch Strom drauf, ja? Auch der Olaf möchte einen Sitzkreis machen, das ist doch eine schöne Idee. Alice, kommst du bitte mal aus der rechten Ecke raus?
Sag vielleicht doch am Ende mehr als ein Michael-Bröker-Podcast, oder?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich find's gut.
Oder das hier?
Du möchtest was spielen, Friedrich? Ja, was willst du denn spielen? Mein rechter rechter Platz ist frei.
Ja, schön.
Alter, musst du mal fragen, ob das jemand mit dir spielen will.
Im Prinzip ja. Also doch sagen wir, nachdem wir die Podcast gehört haben, ist das vielleicht noch das politischste, was man überhaupt so machen kann. Ja, aber auch das hat bald sein Ende, denn es muss jetzt wieder eine Rede geschwungen werden. Das übernimmt Ernst Lustig. So nennt sich diese Figur. Er verkleidet sich mit einer Sonnenblume auf dem Kopf und spielt einen Nachbarn, der sich über vieles aufregt. Zum Beispiel das hier.
Und drum ist ihm Job unverzichtbar heutzutage die Backlife-Balance. Das ist wie die Waldorfschulfriede. Nur tun sie jetzt Chillestadtdanse.
Das wird nochmal so der alte CDU hau-degen gern, dass er nochmal sagt, diese jungen, faulen Leute, die bekommen es hier nochmal ordentlich gezeigt. Aber wir thematisieren ja häufig in diesem Podcast unsere Opernbesuche und auch dieser Nachbar erzähl für einen Opernbesuch. Kannst du dich noch daran erinnern an diese wunderbare Episode, die er erzählt hat oder hast du sie verdrängt?
Ich hab sie verdrängt.
Voriges Wochen kam ein Nachbar rüber, so ein paar feinere Leute. Also ich wollte nur ganz kurz einmal fragen, was machen sie heute? Weil ihr Bekannte nicht kennt, die ins Theater mit sollen. Und jetzt hätten sie zwei Karten noch übrig, die ich nicht euch bringen wollte. Na ja, und meine Frau hat natürlich gleich zu dann gesagt, seht ihr an, es wird die Oper AIDA gebracht. Sascha, ja wenn die gebracht wird. Ich mein, das gab's früher ja nie. Wie ich letztes Mal da war, da musste man ins Theater noch hin.
Spitzenwitz, oder?
Ja. Highlightmoment in diesem Podcast, als wir auf der Bühne einen Auszug aus AIDA spielten, von Nicolas Brownlee gesungen.
Ja.
Das ist natürlich ein Kontrastprogramm.
Geht noch weiter, der Opernbesuch.
Und meine Frau guckt mich bloß an, hat aber auch nicht Logge gelassen, hat mich in so einem auf Ebay gekauften Smoking geschossen, obwohl ich es gar nicht gebraucht hätte. Aber ne, ich bin ja scheinst blöd, komm ich ins Foyer hin, ich hielt da, wo no Smoking drauf steht.
Auch war da auch ein sehr langer Bart schon dieser Witz. Man kann ja immer noch mal bringen. Jetzt hier, ganz toll.
Und dann war mir beinahe noch falsch, aber ich hat es zum Glück noch gesehen, weil unser Platz auf Parkett war und da hat der Bischkelei.
Totenstille im Saal, aber in Mainz nicht. In Mainz freut man sich, dass man sich auch mal über die Hochkultur lustig macht. Die natürlich alle Anwesenden dort im Publikum sowieso auch nur aus der Ferne kennen. Großes AIDA-Finale jetzt.
Ich war zwischen Rikkelein und Vordersitz mit meinen Fiesäugen geklemmt. Plötzlich stumpft mich meine Frau, sie ist so ungeldet, sie schreit. Das war schnell so, wie die rumjault, du der Frau, doch was weh. Dann hat sie mir den Kopf ausgeschüttelt und sieht genervt, junge Junge. Ich war vor Schmerzen am Knie, hätte ich fast schon mit der gesungen. Und in der Pause gab es dann Sekt, haben die anderen uns zu sich gewungen, dann hieß es gleich Stösschen. Ich war noch fällig in meine Schmerzen versunken. Und dann seht ihr, ist ihnen AIDA als Oper, denn überhaupt ein Begriff. Ich hab die erstmals gesehen, da war das noch nicht mal ein Schiff.
Super, super Witzwieder. Also wir müssen überlegen, das ist jetzt die Fernsehsitzung ARD. Man nimmt sich ein Jahr Zeit, um da seine Rede zu präsentieren. Also das ist jetzt nicht jetzt irgendwo mal aus einem Podcast rausgegriffen, wo man sagt, naja, die reden ja auch 100 Stunden die Woche. Nein, das ist jetzt so der eine Moment, wo man sich in Mainz sagt, wir bekommen die bundesrepublikanische Gesamtbühne, Primetime 20.15 Uhr Freitag und das ist das Ergebnis.
Ja, das hab ich auch gedacht, als ich das sah, weil man macht sich ja keine Vorstellungen. Ich habe jetzt so ein bisschen Einblick, als es auch bei uns zu Hause hieß, ja vielleicht spielen wir oder tanzen wir dann unsere Tänze noch mal da und da. Und ich fragte so, wo ist denn das da und so. Und man muss sich das ja so vorstellen, Karneval gerade in diesen Regionen, aber in Frankfurt auch, findet ja in unglaublich vielen Sälen statt. Da sitzen dann 200, 300 Leute oder irgendwie so wie hier ungefähr und dann ist halt Sitzung. Und dann sind so Scouts dabei. Weil es gibt ja die großen Sitzungen, da wo dann auch die Politiker kommen oder hier in Frankfurt mal Josef mal anwesend ist und der ganze Kram. Und am Ende hast du eigentlich so eine mega lange Kette, die man ansonsten so oxen tue, man bewirbt sich jahrelang, diese Slots sind eng und so weiter und so fort. Und es ist wirklich ein hartes, hartes, hartes Geschäft, sein Tanz mal außerhalb des eigenen Vereins und außerhalb der eigenen Sitzung und so zu zeigen. Und dann schaltet man Fernsehen an, wo man weiß, das ist Champions League. Also da sind vier Scouting-Kaskaden durchgelaufen, um das Programm zu bestücken. Und es ist sowas. Also ich versteh es eigentlich gar nicht. Ich hab mich die ganzen vier Stunden darüber gewundert, ob es irgendwo einen Deckel gibt. Also ob du so eine normale Stadtteilsitzung hast. Und das ist eigentlich schon der Gipfel. Also da kommt gar nicht so viel mehr. Und das Fernsehen kann dann im Grunde auch losen.
Aber was macht das uns über unser Land? Also wenn das funktioniert, also das ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass man nur aufgrund von Beziehungen in der ARD vorkommt, sondern das ist ja einfach eine wichtige Sitzung. Und über Mainz hinaus wird das wahrgenommen. Politiker lassen sich, wie wir gleich noch hören werden, gern dort sehen. Was sagt das eigentlich über uns aus, dass wir uns darüber noch mal so als Land verständigen, über jemanden zu lachen, der ein Halloween-Kostüm trägt. Irgendwelche Begriffe werden nicht mehr verwendet. Habeck hat keinen Industriestrompreis gesenkt. Also was ist das für eine Gemütslage, die wir da vorfinden?
Also ich war noch nie in Köln beim Karneval, aber Danny ist ja hier, der kann davon berichten. Der geht schon mit der Zeit. Das können sie aber nicht. Das, was wir hier sehen, ist, klar ich bin jetzt ein bisschen vorgeprägt, ich war die Woche in Athen und so, aber das ist antike Geschichte. Ja. Das ist einfach alles antik.
Aber die ist ja weiterhin da, also in Form von Wählern, in Form von Politikern, die dort sitzen. Also die Wähler und die Politiker, die kann man ja da tatsächlich mal sehen und sie verbinden sich in Form dieser Unterhaltung. Und wenn wir Friedrich Merz auf der Bühne irgendwelche Ansagen machen, hören die dann auch noch eine Pointe beinhalten sollen, dann sind wir ja immer schon im Mähenser Karneval eigentlich.
Aber wenn wir jetzt die Aufgabe hätten, ein Programm zu schreiben, Merz ist ja dadurch aufgefallen, dass er auf der Bühne steht und sagt, Deutschland ist zurück. Oder am Tag eins meiner Kanzlerschaft. Was willst du da noch für Karnevalsprogramm machen?
Stimmt natürlich auch wieder. Aber interessant ist ja, dass das genau nicht aufgegriffen würde. Also wir würden ja sagen, da ist ja das Humor-Potenzial, aber diese unglaubliche Borniertheit, die da drin liegt und die sich ja oft mal noch mal verstärkt hat, ist so charakteristisch für unser Land.
Ich hab eine Idee für nächstes Jahr. Ich schlag sie jetzt vor, vielleicht macht sie nächstes Jahr jemand. Merz hat ja einen spezifischen Namen, der mit seiner Frisur zusammenhängt. Und die müsste man noch mal an diesem spezifischen Teil, blond, lang und mit so einem, weißt du was, hast du es vor Augen? So eine Tram-Tolle auf Merz, aber nur vorne.
Ja, okay.
Vielleicht kann es mal jemand visualisieren, prompten.
Und das willst du dann in der Mainz Abit aufführen?
Ich finde das warte nicht witzig, wenn trotzdem Fritz mit so einer Tram-Tolle vorne.
Ich glaube in Mainz geht das nicht. Also Mainz ist schon sehr CDU treu, sagen wir.
Und dann holt man ihn so auf die Bühne und sagt, aber Fritze, du musst dich jetzt davon trennen. Sie muss jetzt weg.
Habeck ist wieder Thema beim Nachbarn.
Nee komm ich mach fort, sonst krieg ich mit meiner Frau wieder Krach, weil wir kriegen wir im Habeck da jetzt so ein Zerranfeld aufs Dach.
Ja.
Für den Strom selbst zu machen bei sowas wäre ich verrückt. Wir haben früher auch einfach nur auf den Schalter getrickt. Wir hatten auch keine Wallbox am Haus, wo man dann das Auto drauf hängt. Und zwar hat die Oma mir 50 Mark zum Tanken geschenkt. Und wenn der Tank dann halt leer war und du konntest den Keh-Benzinkaufen, dann bist du nicht zum Bäcker gefahren, dann bist du zum Bäcker gelaufen. Ja so war das gewesen und es ging ja mit nicht so viel Geld. Und wir sind auch noch Roller gefahren und haben sie nicht kreisenquerst rottwag gestellt.
Im Prinzip ist das das CDU-Programm. Also ich hab's ja gelesen, es ist ein bisschen länger, aber im Ganzen zusammengefasst kommt das dabei raus.
Man hört auch wie wütend der da ist. Also das ist ja...
Das ist ein Wutbürger. Gut, das ist ein bisschen die Rolle, aber man weiß es nicht.
Der hätte im Grunde so einen Deutschland-Hut aufsetzen müssen.
Du konntest den Keh-Benzinkaufen, dann bist du nicht zum Bäcker gefahren, dann bist du zum Bäcker gelaufen. Ja so war das gewesen und es ging ja mit nicht so viel Geld. Und wir sind auch noch Roller gefahren und haben sie nicht kreisenquerst rottware gestellt.
So und dann hätte er improvisieren müssen in die Fernsehkamera, filmen Sie mir nicht ins Gesicht.
Ja kurz vor dem Herzinfarkt. Zwischendurch gibt es natürlich immer Musik, die habe ich jetzt nicht mitgebracht für die Interessierten. Es war auch die inzwischen 82-jährige Margit Spohnheimer wieder da. Eine Legende. Eine Legende wurde gesagt, eine Legende des Karnevals und natürlich hat sie auch wieder gesungen. Am Rosenmontag bin ich geboren, am Rosenmontag in Mainz am Rhein. Ist aber eine Lüge.
So und jetzt?
Hat sich erst später herausgestellt, dass sie an einem Dienstag geboren ist.
Du hast ja eben gesagt, leider keine Musik. Oh, das ist natürlich auch dramatisch, leider keine Musik. Es gab hier Geraune und Gestöne im Saal, aber jetzt hast du es ja selber gesungen. Wer bevorzugt denn Wolfgang im Vergleich zu diesem Sitzchen? Ich auch.
Das machen wir dann. Nächstes Jahr können wir ja vielleicht dann in der KS noch zu Karneval hier die Sitzung machen.
Wir machen die Sitzung.
Ja.
Wir sind ja Januar, März. Man kann auch im Januar eine Sitzung machen.
Ja, ja.
Wir machen im Januar eine Sitzung. Ne im Dezember. Warte mal, Dezember und März. Ja, wir kriegen das schon hin. Wir machen ja heute auch noch im März. Ja, wir machen nächstes Jahr eine Sitzung.
Ist das überhaupt schon aufgefallen, das Cover? März 25?
Gut, ne?
War seine Idee.
Ist eine Sitzung.
Wie sieht es im Saal aus?
Meine Damen und Herren, an dieser Stelle begrüße ich politische Provinenz im Saal, Landes- und Bundestagsabgeordnete. Herzlich willkommen! Und wenn ich genau hinschaue, da sehe ich zum Beispiel die Julia Knöckner, die Bundesschatzmeisterin der CDU und unsere Bundesinnenministerin Nancy Faese.
Ja, da ist die Stimmung ausgelassen.
Genial.
Nun kommt ein Mann, der in so einem Frauenart Loreley-Kostüm, ich weiß gar nicht, was das so genau ist, Mogunzija nennt sich also diese Figur. Und wer jetzt meint, wird jetzt die Mensa fast nach etwa noch Vogue oder was? Keine Sorge, ganz im Gegenteil.
Die gute Nachricht zuerst, Klaus Weselsky ist im Ruhestand. Um nicht zu sagen, er hat die Bahn freigemacht. Juhu.
Da sind natürlich die alle froh.
Die sind alle wahnsinnig froh, die Leute dort, dass endlich wieder die Züge fahren und die Menschen auch für Kleinstalehrarbeiten gehen.
Ich glaub, wenn man den Saal so sieht, in Mainz bleibt Mainz, also als Fernsehzuschauer denkt man auch, ja, ja, das sind alles Zugfahrer. Die wissen, worum es da geht.
Kindererziehung ist ja für dich ein großes Ding. Du hast dein Buch Kinderwüste jetzt veröffentlicht.
Für uns alle.
Naja für mich nicht.
Ich hab keine.
Aber Kindererziehung ist ja komplett kein Problem.
Du willst auch eine Rente haben? Du willst auch, dass jemand dir die Bußnummer schneidet?
Ich hab gesagt Kindererziehung. Also Kinder erziehen muss ich ja nicht. Ich kann befürworten, dass es Kinder gibt, aber nicht, dass ich sie ja noch erziehe.
Und B, du ruß dich darauf auf, dass jemand anders für dich die Nachwuchse entzieht, ne?
Jetzt hörst du dir hier von Moguntzi mal eine Standpauke an. Das geht nämlich jetzt wohl an die Eltern.
Aber es sind ja auch Sachen passiert im letzten Jahr, ein mit denen hätte gar keiner gerechnet. Zum Beispiel von der letzten Generation habe ich ein Kind gekriegt. Sie wissen ja, Kinder, das sind so kleinere Menschen. Früher hat man die Erzore.
Das ist allerdings nicht verkehrt, es sozusagen. Also nur diesen Teil Kinder. Sie wissen ja, vielleicht haben Sie Freunde, die Freunde haben, die noch wissen, was ein Kind ist. So ungefähr.
Aber er meinte, es ist glaube ich eher so, dass die anti-autoritäre Erziehung sich da bangebrochen hat und da muss jetzt auch wieder zur alten Stränge zurück. Denn vieles an dem modernen Zeitgeist, und damit sind wir schon wieder fast bei den Grünen, stört Mogunziya.
Heute fährt man die durch die Gegend mit solchen Fahrrädern. Da hätte Ditsch früher sein Brezel damit verkauft.
Ja, finde ich witzig, während er selber und das selbst unter Karnevals-Gesichtspunkten, er steht ja auch zum Streitwagen oder so.
Ja, es ist also das Lastenrad hier nochmal als großes Problem angesprochen.
Guckt euch das Foto nochmal an.
Es ist doch wirklich erstaunlich.
Macht sich lustig über Lastenrad-Fahrer. Brutal.
Also man muss sich jetzt mal vorstellen, wir sind also wenige Tage nach der Bundestagswahl, wir haben ja nun wirklich hochpolitisierte Zeiten und Themen, über die man sprechen könnte. Und das einzige, was hier nochmal aufgehoben wird, sind also Lastenrad-Diskussionen, die ja ohnehin schon zwei, drei Jahre alt sind und Habeck-Witze, die ja alle schon vor zehn Monaten im Internet gemacht wurden. Also das zeigt aber auch einfach diese unglaubliche Bräsigkeit in der Republik, die vorherrschend ist und wo man auch sagen kann, ja da kann man nur drüber verzweifeln. Also da kann ja auch Habeck, den wir ja auch mit unterkritisiert haben, aber nicht in diese Richtung, kann ja machen, was er will. Es ist ja überhaupt kein Ankommen gegen diesen stolz vorgetragenen Stumpfsinn, der dort beklatscht wird. Also man beklatscht ja seine eigene Beschränktheit und ruft hellau dazu. Also das finde ich so bemerkenswert, dass man ist so sehr eingesteht und auch noch genießt.
Naja, aber das ist ja, du hast es ja vorhin schon beschrieben, der Wahlzettel und wo ist der Knick.
Ja.
Warum hängen Wahlplakate, damit die Leute wissen, ah, es ist eine Bundestagswahl.
So und so ist das hier auch. Habeck, kenn ich. Ja. Das war es im Grunde.
Das reicht. Nun ist es so, dass es auch bei Moguns ja natürlich um andere Fragen noch geht. Also es ist nicht nur das Lastenrad, sondern wir hören jetzt hier, es geht plötzlich auch um Reiche.
Man hat schließlich jahrzehntelang auf der Überholspur die Milliarden zur Steuervermeidung geschickt umgelenkt. Daher mein Vorschlag, liebe VW-Manager, wenn ihr Cash braucht, ruft doch mal auf den Payment Islands an. Die können euch sicher mal unter die Arme greifen.
Das ist das einzige Mal, dass Superreichtum überhaupt thematisiert wird in der Sitzung und das war es dann auch.
Wäre witziger gewesen, wenn er gesagt hätte, Payment Island.
Ja, du kannst da wirklich noch Vorschläge einreichen, würde ich sagen.
Ich hab einen Freund der GPT.
Aber es wird keineswegs progressiv.
Ja, nicht nur die Union kritisiert, wir haben in Deutschland ein Problem mit unkontrollierter Migration. Liebe Frau Faeser, da hätte sie sich besser mal früher ein Beispiel an der Mainser Fassennacht genommen, weil da sind wir in Mains ja schon seit Jahren Vorbild. Deshalb fragen wir nämlich immer erst vorher. Der Bullemann Reihlaufer!
Ja, Wolle mal in Reihen Reulosse.
Genau.
Das ist also die Frage.
Das ist eine rhetorische Frage.
Die soll sowieso eine rhetorische Frage, aber das ist das, was Felser sich mal als Beispiel erlaubt. Und wir haben jetzt eben gehört, große Applaus, wenn die AfD beschimpft wird als der braune Sumpf und genauso große Applaus, wenn man auch sagt, ja also diese unkontrollierte Migration, hätten sie mal lieber gefragt, soll immer so Reulosse. Also das ist genau dieses radikalisierte Bürgertum, das sich durch die AfD eigentlich noch mal so einen schlanken Fuß machen kann, auf der guten Seite stehen wird ja deshalb, weil man mit der AfD wirklich nichts zu tun hat. Aber sonst will man natürlich auch keine Migranten drin haben. Und es ist interessant, wie diese...
Ups.
Was machst du jetzt?
Der ist irgendwie ausgegangen und ich versuch's wieder anzumachen, aber...
Ah, jetzt ist der Beamer versucht schon aufzugeben.
Ist schon jemand in den Ohnmarkt gefallen? Sollen wir einen Arzt holen? Falls es nicht, ist...
Dein Laptop ist aus dem U, das ist ein kleines technisches Problem.
Nicht so schlimm.
Aber wir brauchen auch glaube ich nur Ton. Nun ist es so, das ist noch ein Lichtblick, ist vielleicht schon zu viel gesagt, aber es gibt noch jemand, der jetzt die Sachen nicht schlimmer macht, sondern vielleicht ein bisschen besser und das ist der schon erwähnte Lars Reichow. Den lässt man aber erst nach 23.20 Uhr auftreten, damit da nicht Leute verwirrt werden.
Meine Tochter, wie gesagt, wir haben das geguckt wegen Tagesschau. Sie meinte dann nach drei Stunden, ich gehe jetzt ins Bett. Und dann kam er. Und ich hab kurz überlegt, nein, ich bin ein vernünftiger Vater, ich lass sie jetzt schlafen.
Ja, also so doll war es jetzt auch nicht.
Doch, doch, doch, doch, doch.
Damit wir morgen wieder kraftvoll in den Spiegel schauen können, um über den großen Teich zu rufen. Wir sind gerne eure Freunde, liebe Amerikaner, aber wir möchten nichts zu tun haben mit diesem miesen Haufen von Milliardären im Oval Office, die gleich am ersten Tag nichts Besseres zu tun hatten, als die Welthungerhilfe auf Null zu stellen.
Genau.
Schämt euch! Shame on you!
Shame on you! Ja.
Als nächstes.
Der Wählerwille ist eindeutig. Sarah Wagenknecht wird demnächst eine Dutch-Unweit von Moskau beziehen. Bitte auch Oscar mitnehmen.
Das ist ja witzig.
Naja, also den Witz hab ich ja jetzt aber auch schon vor zehn Jahren mal auf Twitter gehört.
Ich hab das ja drei, vorher in real-time geguckt und ich dann plötzlich fand ich so witzig.
Aus Verzweiflung lacht man natürlich irgendwann, dass wenigstens ein bisschen was kommt. Aber jetzt interessant, also wir haben jetzt, ich hab gar nicht alle mitgebracht, aber wir haben natürlich jetzt ein Dutzendmal gehört, wie schlimm Habeck und die Grünen so sind.
Tja, ich darf das hier mal so deutlich sagen, die Grünen waren nicht immer perfekt, sie waren auch nicht immer geschickt, aber sie sind auch nicht immer an allem schuld.
Der Applaus ist etwas vorsichtiger, tatsächlich, aber er traut es sich zu sagen. Und das ist jetzt wirklich schon fast die Fundamentalopposition, die man im Saal einnehmen kann. So verrückt ist das jetzt.
Das kommt hier nicht so richtig rüber. Ihr müsst euch jetzt, ihr habt das schon drei Stunden lang gesehen und so weiter.
Ihr habt jetzt immer gehört, Wärmepumpe, Heizhammer etc. Und jetzt kommt nach drei Stunden jemand sagt, also die Grünen auch nicht nur schlecht. Ach so, was machen wir denn jetzt mit so einer Info? Die Sache ist jetzt allerdings, dass er auf das Migrationsthema richtig zu sprechen kommt, aber nur die AfD-Wähler leider adressiert. Er müsste wirklich jetzt sagen und das gilt auch für die Ampel, das gilt auch für gerade die CDU, die jetzt diese Migrationsbeschlüsse fasst. Er kapriziert sich auf die AfD-Wähler, inhaltlich aber ist ihm natürlich zuzustimmen. Das ist im Prinzip das Argument, das wir hier in diesem Podcast schon sehr, sehr häufig gemacht haben.
Und die Nummer eins seit 88 Wochen, Ausländer raus. Eine Bitte habe ich an alle AfD-Wähler, holt doch schon mal eure Eltern aus den Seniorenstiften heraus. Da wimmelt es nämlich nur so von ausländischen Fachkräften. Holt sie schon mal raus. Und sucht euch schon mal ein Krankenhaus, in dem nur deutsches Personal arbeitet. Schaut in die Gastronomie, in die Fußballvereine, in die Musikvereine.
Als ich das gehört habe, ich hab so gedacht, ja, das ist genau richtig. Das ist wie eine Szenerie aus Bielefeld. Andre Kieserling ist in irgendeinem Museum und redet da so mit dem gemeinen Volke. Und dann kommt da irgendso jemand und sagt, ach, der Kapitalismus, was soll denn der Scheiß und so. Und dann ist die Antwort von Kieserling, haben sie ihr Konto schon gekündigt? Also was willst du für eine kluge, soziologische oder politische Diskussion führen? Und so hier auch. Ach so, haben sie die Oma schon aus dem Alten einabgeholt? Fertig. Das ist die ganze Diskussion.
Absolut richtig. Ich verstehe nur nicht, warum er nur sich auf die AfD-Wähler konzentriert. Also das war eigentlich das große Versäumnis dieser gesamten Sitzung. Und das ist ja spiegelbildlich für das, was wir in der Bundesrepublik jetzt gerade im ganzen Leben, nämlich, dass immer noch eigentlich nur das Problem AfD gesehen wird und nicht gesehen wird, dass die anderen sich in die AfD längst auch verwandelt haben, zumindest teilweise. Und dass man dadurch immer noch so aussieht, als würde man zu den Richtigen gehören, weil man ja egal was man macht, auf keinen Fall AfD ist, denn von denen hat man sich ja schon vielfach distanziert. Und das ist eigentlich diese paradoxe Situation, die in dieser Sitzung noch mal so ganz deutlich klar wird, gerade dann, wenn sich gegen rechts positioniert wird, dann meint das immer nur noch die AfD. Und dass man selbst dahin rückt, ist dann Realpolitik, Vernunft, haben es auch alle ein bisschen wild getrieben, Merkel hat es ja zu verantworten. Also das ist eigentlich jetzt so eine neue Lage, die wir sehen. Und da, wenn wir uns mal erinnern, wie es war, als tatsächlich Merkel viele Flüchtlinge hat kommen lassen, wie da die Stimmung war, da war sie eine generell migrationsfreundliche gewesen. Da war das generell nicht so gewesen, dass man sich nach rechts bewegt hat. Und sonst, und jetzt haben wir eigentlich diese Situation, dass die AfD als nützliche Funktion installiert ist, um sich selbst davon reinzuhalten. Und das ist eigentlich das, was man hier so zur Konstituierung der Mitte der Gesellschaft sehen kann. Man braucht noch so ein Außen und das kann dann die AfD sein, ist dann manchmal aber auch noch Wagenknecht mit der Datscher und Putin und so weiter. Dadurch kann man sich natürlich selbst in der Mitte ganz wohlfühlen und glaubt immer noch, dass man eigentlich diese Mitte gar nicht verlassen hat. Dass aber die Mitte im Ganzen woanders hingewandert ist, kriegt man gar nicht mehr mit.
Aber zur Ehrenrettung, in der Kritik von außen von dir ist er hier auf Augenhöhe mit Sandra Maischberger, Dunja Hayali, Marietta Slomka. Und das ist für eine Karnevalsveranstaltung schon ganz schön gut.
Das kann man so sagen, beziehungsweise es ist interessant, wie also diese diskursiven Hegemonien, die wir da in den Talkshows feststellen, sich dann einfach nochmal eins zu eins, leicht variiert im Karneval wiederfinden lassen. Also es ist nicht so, dass da nochmal eine Gegenwelt aufgemacht wird oder so, oder dass da wirklich ein Kontrapunkt gesetzt wird, sondern man bestätigt eigentlich nochmal See- und Denkgewohnheiten und unterfüttert sie mit dem ein mehr oder weniger gelungenen Witz. Auch bemerkenswert ist, dass ja hier Reichow vorwiegend auf Pointen verzichtet, sondern eigentlich schon fast eine bundespräsidiale Ansprache wählt. So nämlich endet diese Rede.
Liebe Freunde, Freiheit ist ein Privileg. Die Fastnacht ist das Sahnehäubchen. Die Demokratie ein Geschenk. Sie ist die beste, die gerechteste und erfolgreichste Staatsform der Welt. Mit den glücklichsten Menschen.
Im Prinzip will es ja so Frank-Walter Steinmeier auch gerne machen, aber da fehlt ihm dann der Elan.
Aber man muss hier wieder sagen kritisch, ich möchte es kritisch anmerken. Es war schon der Moment, dass man so dachte, okay, dann kann ich ja jetzt geruhsam ins Bett gehen. Also sozusagen die Ansage an Oma Erna, nichts weiter passiert. Es waren zwar keine Nachrichten im Fernsehen, aber nichts passiert.
Das heißt, du hast den Schluss mit den Mainzer Hof-Sängern dir nicht mehr angesehen?
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Das sind so Männer in ja Harlekin-Kostümen, die dann opernhaft so ein Tag so wunderschön wie heute singen.
Ne, das ist ja dann Auszugsmarsch, da verlasse ich typischerweise den Saal.
Ja.
Eigentlich mit meiner Tochter, aber die war ja schon im Bett. Und in dem Falle bin ich dann Zähneputzen gegangen.
Ich fand's jedenfalls richtig schlimm, aber so ist nun gerade die Situation im Lande. Und dann kann man froh sein, dass es doch auch noch andere Stimmen gibt. Nicht hier im Rheinland oder so, sondern wir müssen da zum Nockherberg. Dort war ja jetzt auch wieder dieses Singspiel. Und dort sprach einmal mehr Maxi Schafroth. Seine Rede ist dort sehr hart mit den Politikern, die dort sitzen, tatsächlich ins Gericht gegangen. Und er thematisiert im Gegensatz zu all diesen Herrschaften bei Mainz Black Mainz tatsächlich einmal den Erfolg der Linkspartei. Und hier können wir uns ja mal fragen, ob das nicht eigentlich die adäquate Ansprache wäre, die man bei Mainz Black Mainz vermisst hat.
Wenn du Ordnungsgelder für Stilllosigkeit im Wahlkampf verhängen könntest, dann bräuchte der Markus nochmal ein Sondervermögen.
Und man muss dazu sagen, Markus Söder sitzt dann da. Und er sieht nicht glücklich aus.
Und dann holen die Linken plötzlich auf mit Fakten. Gibt's denn sowas? Die sprechen doch tatsächlich das an, was die Leute umtreibt. Da muss doch bei euch hier vorne klingeln. Vielleicht wollen die Leute eine klare Sprache, dass die Dinge benannt werden, die einem ins Auge springen. Zum Beispiel, dass man mit Blick auf die Einkommensstruktur in diesem Land ja mal drauf kommen könnte, dass es ein bisschen viel Elite gibt. Vier neue Milliardäre pro Woche. Wir können hier oben gar nicht so viel nachbestuhen, wie Platz haben müssen. Dann ruft die Union, die FDP wieder, Nightdebatte, Nightdebatte. Das muss man erklären. Mit Nightdebatte ist gemeint, wenn man zum Beispiel dem Fritzi Merz Seid-Cesna nicht vergönnt. Ja, mein Gott, Leute, pilot and command Merz Seid-Cesna ist der VW Golf des Juristen. Bitte, diese Nightdebatte, interessant ist schon, dass die Nightdebatte, die sich nach oben richtet, verpönt ist. Aber die Nightdebatte, die sich nach unten richtet, der Neid der Geringverdiener auf die Bürgergeldempfänger, der scheint ja geradezu erwünscht zu sein. Die Nightdebatte nach unten wird eingeschürt wie ein Kaminfeuer in der Märzischen Jagdhütte. Da stoßen wir drauf an, dass Reich reich bleibt und arm arm.
Prost beinandert.
Und so ist die Stimmung da.
Stimmungsgrad.
Da darf keiner mehr was. Und das könnte Karneval, das könnte Fastnacht auch sein. Und genau das findet man nicht. Das sind die Ausnahmen, die man dann dort beim Nockherberg mal präsentiert bekommen. Und es ist tatsächlich genau das, was ja eigentlich adressiert werden müsse. Und all das, was wir da bei Mainz bleibt Mainz sehen, ist im Prinzip der Karneval, den du uns jetzt vorgeführt hast mit den Männer Podcasts. Das heißt, wir sind in einer Situation, wo eigentlich alles offen benannt werden könnte und mitunter findet man diese Stimmen. Aber im Ganzen bleibt es so wie es ist. Mainz bleibt Mainz. Das ist quasi dann auch wirklich die Ansage, alles bleibt wie es ist. Und ja, keine Umverteilung.
Ja, was will man mehr?
Ja, das sind quasi jetzt die Vorbereitungen auf die Märzkanzlerschaft. Also Mainz bleibt Mainz hat jetzt quasi den Grundstein dafür gelegt. In diese Richtung wird es gehen. Hin und wieder dann gibt es spitze Kritik vom Nockherberg aus. Aber sonst kann man sich auf einiges gefasst machen. Dennoch bleiben wir unverzagt in gewisser Weise, beschäftigen uns weiter mit dem, was der politische Diskurs und was sonst noch so der Zeitgeist anzubieten hat und freuen uns, wenn wir uns dann Ende des Monats wieder hören.
Yeah, es ist wieder Frühling.